par à tous bienvenue pour deux heures
d'émission nous décrypterons comme
chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
une actualité consacrée à l'allocution
d'emmanuel macron dans quelques instants
extension du pass sanitaire vaccination
obligatoire des soignants réforme de fin
du quinquennat
que va décider emmanuel macron le chef
de l'état doit s'adresser aux français
ce sera dans quelques instants à 20h
pile une allocution programmée pour
durer une petite demi-heure aux plaines
propagation du variant delta désormais
majoritaires sur tout le territoire le
conseil scientifique qui guide le
gouvernement appelle à de nouvelles
mesures pour éviter une quatrième vague
nous consacrerons une grande partie de
cette émission à ces annonces nous les
décrypteront bien évidemment ensuite
avec nos invités en duplex avec nous et
nos analystes
[Musique]
une prise de parole ni initialement
prévu donc pour permettre emmanuel
macron d'évoquer les dernières réformes
de son quinquennat avant l'élection
présidentielle mais la crise sanitaire
en a décidé autrement l'épidémie
redémarre en france en raison du variant
delta désormais majoritaires sur le
territoire plusieurs axes pour lutter
contre le coc vide
emmanuel macron ne manquera certainement
pas d'évoquer la vaccination obligatoire
des soignants certaines indiscrétions de
source parlementaire indique qu'une loi
passerait bientôt prochainement en
conseil des ministres rendant donc la
vaccination obligatoire on appris dans
le même temps que la grèce venait de la
rendre obligatoire et place au direct
allocution du président de la république
française français mes chers
compatriotes d'hexagone d'outre- mer et
de l'étranger
comme depuis le début de la pandémie je
tiens à m'adresser directement à vous
après m'être beaucoup déplacé après
avoir été à votre rencontre partout en
france
après avoir longuement consulté où en
sommes nous de notre combat contre le
coc vie de 19 grâce à l'engagement
exceptionnel de nos soignants grâce à
votre civisme à tous nous avons réussi à
maîtriser l'épidémie et à revivre à
nouveau nos effort proportionné la
réouverture progressive et réussi des
mois de mai et juin et le déploiement
d'un plan de vaccination inédit nous ont
permis d'obtenir des résultats
incontestables
nous étions parvenus au cours de ces
dernières semaines à passer sous les
2000 contamination par jour contre plus
de 35000 au plus haut de la crise les
hospitalisations comme les décès sont au
plus bas depuis près d'un an en vous
disant tout cela je pense évidemment aux
victimes et à leurs proches
la vie malgré tout a pu continuer durant
ces mois difficiles parce que nous nous
sommes organisés collectivement si nous
avons demandé beaucoup aux enseignants
aux parents d'élèves qui ont dû
s'adapter dans l'urgence quand soudain
une classe fermée si nous avons demandé
beaucoup aussi à nos élèves et nos
étudiants
la france a largement préservés
l'instruction durant cette crise douze
semaines de fermeture pour nos écoles
depuis mars 2020 alors qu'aux états unis
les écoles ont fermé durant cinquante
six semaines ou en allemagne durant 34
semaines certains cours ont pu reprendre
physiquement à l'université ces derniers
mois nous pouvons être fiers de cela de
ce choix collectif de la nation d'avoir
fait le maximum pour l'avenir de nos
enfants et d'autre et de notre jeunesse
cet été comme à la rentrée nous
accentuerons encore nos efforts pour
apporter un soutien renforcé aux élèves
et aux étudiants qui rencontrent des
difficultés sur le plan économique le
quoi qu'il en coûte auquel je m'étais
engagé dès mars 2020 non seulement nous
a permis de protéger nos entreprises nos
emplois mais à préserver le pouvoir
d'achat de nombre de français et est à
l'origine d'un vigoureux rebond notre
croissance devrait s'établir à à 6% en
2021 en tête des grandes économies
européennes la france pour la deuxième
année consécutive a été désigné comme le
pays le plus attractif d'europe
contrairement aux prévisions l'emploi a
résisté et les acquis obtenus depuis
2010 est en termes de baisse dues somme
du chômage sont préservés en 2020 le coc
vide a détruit près de 300000 emplois
depuis le début de l'année nous avons
déjà re créé 187 milles emplois
ce seul mois de mai nous avons atteint
un nombre de contrats à durée
indéterminée créé inédit égalant notre
record de 2006 dans tous les secteurs
qui comme la culture l'hôtellerie la
restauration le sport le tourisme ont le
plus souffert
chacun reconnaît que les plans de
soutien spécifique que nous avons mises
en oeuvre ont permis d'empêcher les
drames humains les faillites et
d'envisager une reprise sereine nous
restons pleinement mobilisés pour aider
ceux qui ont subi la crise plus
fortement que d'autres
les salariés travaillant dans les
entreprises qui n'ont pas résisté
où les jeunes comme les indépendants qui
durant cette période sont
malheureusement tombés dans la pauvreté
je veux vous dire ce soir que nous avons
eu raison collectivement de rechercher
sans cesse l' équilibre entre la
protection et la liberté raison au début
de cette année de protéger la vie sans
pour autant refermer le pays
cette situation maîtrisée c'est le fruit
de nos choix de nos efforts ces choix et
nos résultats nous permettent d'aborder
les difficultés qui sont encore devant
nous avec détermination
car oui
à l'heure où je vous parle notre pays
est confronté à une reprise forte de
l'épidémie qui touche tous les
territoires métropole comme outre-mer
aussi longtemps que le virus circulera
nous serons confrontés à ce type de
situation l'apparition du variant dit
delta se traduit en effet par une
augmentation des contaminations partout
dans le monde parce que ce variant est
trois fois plus contagieux que la
première souche il s'engouffre dans tous
les espaces non couverts par la
vaccination
pour y faire face de nouvelles mesures
de restriction ont été décidées aux pays
bas au portugal ou en espagne en asie et
dans le pacifique certains pays ont dû
se résoudre à 1 re confinement et le
japon imaginez qu'ils s'apprêtent à
organiser les jeux olympiques le fera
sans aucun spectateur
et si chez nous en france la situation
est pour le moment maîtrisé
si nous n'agissons pas dès aujourd'hui
le nombre de cas va continuer de monter
fortement et entraînera inévitablement
des hospitalisations en hausse dès le
mois d'août nous avons pour faire face à
cette nouvelle donne un atout maître qui
change tout par rapport aux vagues
précédentes le vaccin tous les vaccins
disponibles en france nous protège
solidement contre ce variant delta il
divise par 12 son pouvoir de
contamination et évite 95% des formes
graves
l'équation est simple plus nous
vaccinerons - nous laisserons des
espaces au virus pour se diffuser plus
nous éviterons les hospitalisations et
plus nous éviterons d'autres mutations
du virus peut être plus dangereux encore
c'est donc une nouvelle course de
vitesse qui est engagée un été de
mobilisation pour la vaccination
voilà ce que nous devons viser vacciner
un maximum de personnes partout à tout
moment
nous sommes une grande nation une nation
de science celle des lumières de louis
pasteur
alors quand la science nous offre les
moyens de nous protéger nous devons les
utiliser avec confiance dans la raison
et dans le progrès pour nous protéger et
pour
autre unité nous devons aller vers la
vaccination de tous les français
car c'est le seul chemin vers le retour
à la vie normale dans un premier temps
pour les personnels soignants et non
soignants des hôpitaux des cliniques des
maisons de retraite des établissements
pour personnes en situation de handicap
pour tous les professionnels ou
bénévoles qui travaillent au contact des
personnes âgées ou fragiles y compris à
domicile
la vaccination sera rendue obligatoire
sans attendre j'ai conscience de ce que
je vous demande
je sais que vous êtes prêts à cet
engagement cela participe ou quelque
sorte de votre sens du devoir pour tous
nos compatriotes concernés ils auront
jusqu'au 15 septembre pour se faire
vacciner
il faut commencer dès maintenant à
partir du 15 septembre des contrôles
seront opérés et des sanctions seront
prises et ensuite tous les autres
françaises et français les millions
d'entre vous qui n'ont pour le moment
reçu aucune injection en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation nous devrons
sans doute nous poser la question de la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous les
français mais je fais le choix de la
confiance et j'appelle solennellement
tous nos concitoyens non vaccinés à
aller se faire vacciner dès aujourd'hui
au plus vite
9 millions de doses vous attendre dès
aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas encore été
injectés et nos commandes continuent
d'arriver
que ce soit donc près de chez vous sur
votre lieu de vacances avec ou sans
rendez vous faites vous vacciner
c'est la seule façon de vous protéger et
de protéger les autres
c'est une question de responsabilité
individuelle de sens de l'esprit
collectif 7e au 6e dont dépend notre
liberté à toutes et tous
je pense en particulier à tous nos
concitoyens de plus de 60 ans et aux
personnes vulnérables dont celles qui
sont en surpoids graves qu'ils sont pas
encore vaccinés aujourd'hui vous êtes
celles et ceux qui courent est
aujourd'hui le plus grand danger
j'en appelle donc à votre mobilisation
nous déploierons durant tout l'été la
vaccination au plus près du terrain
en travaillant étroitement avec nos
médecins nos pharmaciens mais aussi nos
associations dont je veux saluer
l'engagement et nous irons vacciner
celles et ceux qui sont aussi le plus
loin des soins pour les collégiens les
lycéens les étudiants des campagnes de
vaccination spécifique seront déployés
dans les établissements scolaires dès la
rentrée
je veux m'adresser enfin à ceux qui
vacciner les premiers c'est à dire en
janvier et février verront prochainement
leur taux d'anticorps baissé et leur
immunité diminué je veux ici les
rassurer dès la rentrée une campagne de
rappel sera mise en place pour vous
permettre de bénéficier d'une nouvelle
injection selon le même système et dans
les mêmes conditions que la ou les
premières les rendez vous pourront être
pris dès les premiers jours du mois de
septembre
il n'y a donc pas d'inquiétude à avoir
mais malgré le vaccin je vous demande à
toutes et tous de continuer à être
prudents et de continuer à respecter ces
gestes barrière contre le virus que vous
connaissez bien désormais en complément
de la vaccination nous allons devoir
mettre en place de nouvelles mesures
pour freiner le virus parce que le
niveau de vaccination y est encore très
insuffisant et que les hôpitaux sont
déjà sous forte pression forte pression
l'état d'urgence sanitaire sera déclaré
dès demain en conseil des ministres pour
la martinique et la réunion et un
couvre-feu sera instauré pour autant
dans l'hexagone sauf dans les
départements qui dépasserait un taux
d'incidence de 200 et verrait leur
hospitalisation augmenter ou des mesures
de freinage pourront être prise par le
préfet notre approche sera plus simple
partout nous aurons la même démarche
reconnaître le civisme et faire porter
les restrictions sur les noms vague
ciné plutôt que sur tous dès cette
semaine les contrôles aux frontières
seront encore renforcées pour les
ressortissants en provenance des pays à
risque avec un isolement contre un pour
les voyageurs non vaccinés dès le 21
juillet le pass sanitaire sera étendue
aux lieux de loisirs et de culture
concrètement pour tous nos compatriotes
de plus de 12 ans il faudra pour accéder
à un spectacle un parc d'attractions un
concert ou un festival avoir été
vaccinés ou présenter un test négatif
récents ce pass est disponible sur
l'application tout senti qu vide mais
chacun peut utiliser la version papier
remise au moment de la vaccination à
partir du début du mois d'août
et cela parce qu'il nous faut faire
d'abord voté un texte de loi le
promulguer à partir du début du mois
d'août donc le pass sanitaire
s'appliquera dans les cafés les
restaurants les centres commerciaux
ainsi que dans les hôpitaux les maisons
de retraite établissements médicaux
sociaux
je suis dans les avions trains et cars
pour les longs trajets là encore seuls
les vaccinés et les personnes testées
négatives pourront accéder à ces lieux
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs clients usagers
ou salariés en fonction de l'évaluation
de la situation nous nous poserons la
question de l'extension du pass
sanitaires à d'autres activités encore
cet automne les fameux tests pcr seront
rendus payants
sauf prescription médicale et ceci afin
d'encourager la vaccination plutôt que
la multiplication des tests pour pouvoir
faire tout cela je convoquerai le
parlement en session extraordinaire à
partir du 21 juillet pour l'examen d'un
projet de loi qui déclinera ses
décisions vous l'avez compris la
vaccination n'est pas tout de suite
obligatoire pour tout le monde mais nous
allons étendre au maximum le pass
sanitaires pour pousser le maximum
d'entre vous à aller vous faire vacciner
enfin nous continuerons d'agir pour
éviter l'apparition de variants qui
pourrait être plus dangereux encore que
le variant delta cela passe par un
projet immense mais indispensable est
désormais à notre portée vacciner le
monde
la france depuis mars 2020 et à
l'initiative avec le programme act as
qui vise à la fois produire davantage de
vaccins et a donné aux pays les plus
pauvres
davantage de vaccins nous avons déjà
donné plus de deux millions et demi de
doses et d'ici la fin de l'année donnant
plusieurs dizaines de millions de doses
de vaccins
nous contribuerons à nous mobiliser
justement et à mobiliser tous nos
partenaires pour produire plus et donner
encore davantage aux pays les plus
pauvres en particulier dans les balkans
en afrique au proche et au moyen-orient
plusieurs pays sont eux aujourd'hui
fortement touchés et nous allons
accroître encore notre aide et je pense
particulièrement à la tunisie pour en
finir durablement avec la pandémie
nous devons vacciner partout je vous
l'avais dit l'année dernière nous
allions devoir vivre avec le virus
ce sera le cas tout au long de cette
année 2021 et sans doute pour plusieurs
mois encore de l'année 2022
même si le vaccin change beaucoup de
choses les semaines à venir seront donc
celle de la mobilisation pour bloquer le
virus et pour continuer de relancer
notre économie
l'été de mobilisation pour la
vaccination sera aussi un été de relance
gelé constaté au cours de mes récents
échanges avec vous partout en france
notre plan de relance se déploie un
rythme soutenu sur les 100 milliards
d'euros votés à l'automne dernier et
permet grâce à l'accord européen
historique d'il ya un an 40 milliards
ont ainsi été mobilisés sur le terrain
nous devons faire plus encore car plus
vite nous concrétiserons le plan de
relance plus fort sera notre rebond plus
relance plus efficace sera notre lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique
un tiers des crédits sont en effet ciblé
sur la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments sur les énergies décarbonées
sur l'automobile zéro émission tous les
secteurs qui concilie écologie et
économie écologie et progrès le
gouvernement et les préfets s'assureront
durant l'été de la bonne mise en oeuvre
des investissements sur le terrain nous
allons aussi faire le maximum pour lever
les contraintes
qui pèsent sur les secteurs justement
qui sont les plus en tension et sur vous
tous d'abord le manque de matières
premières qu'il s'agisse de bois d'acier
de fer ou du semiconducteur ce qui a
retardé de nombreux chantiers et fait
monter les coûts ensuite les pénuries de
main d'oeuvre
selon la banque de france près d'une
entreprise sur deux ne trouvent pas de
réponses à ces offres d'emploi il faut
ainsi tout faire ensemble sur le terrain
pour y répondre et responsabiliser
chacun notre priorité de l'été et de
l'automne est bien de retrouver non
seulement le niveau d'emploi d'avant
l'épidémie mais ne doute de nous
réinscrire dans une trajectoire de plein
emploi
si nous nous mobilisons pour nous
vacciner pour relancer l'économie alors
nous serons en mesure en septembre de
préparer collectivement notre avenir
il nous faudra en débattre de manière
apaisée et démocratique
il nous faudra aussi prendre des
décisions mais je veux d'ores et déjà
partager avec vous quelques convictions
fortes
la première c'est la nécessité de moins
dépendre de l'étranger pour certains
produits essentiels certains services
certaines technologies c'est la
nécessité de retrouver le chemin d'une
indépendance française et européenne
parce que nous avons vécu durant cette
crise les conséquences de la dépendance
grâce à l'action menée depuis 2010 est
nous sommes en train de réussir de nous
améliorer les productions majeures pour
la vie du pays comme celles de
paracétamol par exemple ont été
relocalisés en france une usine géante
de batteries pour nos véhicules
électriques va prochainement ouvrir sur
nos terres industrielles du nord et
préfigurer des investissements massifs
dans la transformation de l'industrie
automobile j'ai lancé le mois dernier un
plan d'investissement de 7 milliards
d'euros pour l'innovation en matière de
santé d usine de la recherche chez nous
en france
nous sommes depuis deux ans la première
nation européenne du numérique et de la
technologie
nous devons donc continuer d'investir et
encourager ces initiatives qui ont créé
plus de 160 mille emplois ce défi
désormais qui est le nôtre et de changer
d'échelle de généraliser partout cette
dynamique de redevenir une grande nation
de recherche d'innovation d'agriculture
et d'industrie réindustrialiser
réconcilier la croissance et l'écologie
de production au niveau national la
baisse des impôts de production ainsi
que celle de l'impôt sur les sociétés
que nous avons décidé vont permettre
d'accélérer ce mouvement au niveau
européen la présidence française de
l'union européenne qui commencera le 1er
janvier 2022 nous permettra de bâtir un
agenda commun d'indépendance industriel
et technologique à la rentrée après le
travail et les consultations en cours
nous déciderons d'un plan
d'investissement qui visera un objectif
bâtir la france de 2030 et faire émerger
dans notre pays et en europe
les champions de demain qui dans les
domaines du numérique de l'industrie
verte des biotechnologies ou encore de
l'agriculture dessinant notre avenir
la deuxième conviction c'est que nous
avons vu la force durant cette crise de
notre modèle social et la protéger nos
entreprises nos emplois notre culture de
nombreux secteurs exposés et la protéger
notre pouvoir d'achat durant la crise
c'est un joyau qu'il nous faut préserver
ce modèle social français repose sur un
fondement le travail sans travail pas de
production sans travail sans production
pas de financement de notre santé pas de
financement du chômage partiel pas de
financement de nos retraites
la priorité de la sortie de crise sera
donc la même que depuis le début du
quinquennat le travail et le mérite
c'est pour cela que nous allons
continuer d'investir dans la formation
tout au long de la vie dès cette rentrée
nous formons durablement plus de
demandeurs d'emploi qu'il ya quatre ans
mais ce n'est pas encore assez et j'ai
demandé au gouvernement dès cette
rentrée de lancer un plan massif de
formation et de requalification les
chômeurs de longue durée
c'est pour cela que la réforme de
l'assurance chômage sera pleinement
mises en oeuvre dès le 1er octobre
autour d'une volonté simple en france on
doit toujours bien mieux gagner sa vie
en travaillant qu'en restant chez soi ce
qui n'est actuellement pas toujours le
cas
c'est pour cela aussi que nous devrons
engager dès que les conditions
sanitaires seront réunies la réforme des
retraites
j'ai toujours tenu un langage de vérité
oui notre système est injuste
avec quarante deux régimes différents il
entretient des inégalités majeur et il
faudra aller vers plus de simplicité
pour plus de justice et donc les régimes
spéciaux devront être supprimés pour les
nouveaux employés dans ces secteurs
pas demain pas brutalement il nous
faudra travailler plus longtemps et
partir à la retraite plus tard pas
demain pas brutalement pas de manière
uniforme car il faut prendre en compte
la difficulté des métiers mais
progressivement sur plusieurs années et
par un système qui fait la différence
selon le travail réellement exercées et
donc l'âge de départ doit être plus
tardif oui une vie de travail doit
offrir une pension digne et donc toute
retraite pour une carrière complète
devrait être supérieur à 1000 euros par
mois voilà ce que je veux
en des termes clairs et simples pour
protéger les retraites actuelles et
celles de nos enfants sans augmenter les
impôts
il est juste et efficace de changer
notre système de retraite
j'ai entendu les débats sur le moment
faut-il faire cette réforme dès ce mois
de juillet à la rentrée ou bien plus
tard alors si je demande aux
gouvernements de jean castex de
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
sur ce sujet
dès la rentrée je ne lancerai pas cette
réforme tant que l'épidémie ne sera pas
sous contrôle et la reprise bien assurer
ma troisième conviction enfin c'est que
la nation doite une réponse à ceux qui
ont été le plus touchés par la crise à
notre jeunesse qui a tant sacrifié alors
qu'elles risquaient peu pour elle même à
nos aînés qui plus que les autres on
craint pour leur vie pour notre jeunesse
nous devons continuer d'investir
investir dans la petite enfance dans
l'éducation
cela demeure plus que jamais notre
priorité en sortie de crise pour nos
jeunes adultes
nos étudiants comme nos jeunes actifs ou
nos jeunes qui sont peu formés
nous avons créé la plateforme un jeune
une solution nous poursuivrons ce
programme qui a permis à deux millions
de jeunes de trouver une formation de
décrocher parfois un emploi de signer
souvent un contrat d'apprentissage
imaginez 526 mille contrats
d'apprentissage en 2020 ce qui est un
record pour amplifier cette dynamique je
présenterai à la rentrée le revenu
d'engagement pour les jeunes qui
concernera les jeunes sans emploi ou
formation et sera fondé sur une logique
de devoir est de droit quant à nos aînés
et nos concitoyens en situation de
handicap trop souvent confrontés à une
solitude sans solution nous leur devons
une grande ambition humaniste pour
l'autonomie un accompagnement renforcé
pour le maintien à domicile des maisons
de retraite moderniser accompagnement de
notre jeunesse meilleure prise en charge
des aînés c'est un nouveau pacte
français entre les générations qu'il
nous faut bâtir pour notre nation
cette ambition devra être financé et ce
ne sera pas par une hausse d'impôts
là aussi je demeure constant avec la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation la
baisse des cotisations sociales
la diminution de l'impôt sur le revenu
ce qui représente 170 euros en plus par
mois pour un salarié au smic
nous avons assumé d'améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat est de baisser les impôts
une priorité pour les classes moyennes
et nous ne reviendrons pas en arrière
nos réformes ne seront pas davantage
financer en laissant filer la dette
la nouvelle génération doit déjà assumer
la dette écologique je n'ajouterai pas à
ce fardeau
la dette financière la seule solution le
seul moyen d'assurer ce nouveau pacte
est de travailler davantage d'investir
d'innover d'inventer d'améliorer notre
croissance est de continuer à réformer
réformer l'état comme nous avons
commencé à le faire avec la réforme de
la haute fonction publique et la
suppression de l'ena de simplifier le
mille-feuille territorial de simplifier
partout où c'est possible
l'action publique la seule solution est
de continuer à bousculer le système et
les positions établies les rentes les
statuts c'est ainsi que nous reprendrons
le contrôle de notre destin comme nation
c'est ainsi que nous reprendrons chacun
le contrôle de nos vies comme citoyen la
volonté que la france doit porter bien
celle-là reprendre le contrôle de notre
destin garantir à chacune et chacun des
nôtres qu'il pourra retrouver de son
destin personnel professionnel familial
et civiques
bien des questions devront trouver les
réponses dans les mois qui viennent que
je n'ai pas ici abordée dans le cadre de
ce message ce soir j'ai bien entendu
entendu l'inquiétude que fait naître la
montée d'une violence endémique dont
sont victimes les plus fragiles les
femmes souvent y compris dans le couple
de jeunes adolescents dans la rue et le
manque de respect à l'égard des forces
de l'ordre de sécurité j'ai entendu le
message pour
et à l'endroit de nos institutions par
l'abstention impressionnante aux
élections régionales et départementales
et j'ai en tête les questions qui
portent sur les équilibres de notre
démocratie
devant toutes ces questions j'ai une
certitude nous devons non seulement
prolonger notre effort mais le
renouveler en inventant chaque jour le
nouveau modèle que notre pays et le
monde attendent et des choses dans le
monde sont en train de bouger aussi
grâce à des initiatives que proposait
soutient la france il faudra se souvenir
que c'est en ces premiers jours de l'été
2021 que la communauté internationale
dans un effort sans précédent a décidé
d'une imposition mondial des
multinationales à 15 % minimum mettant
ainsi fin aux évasions fiscales et aux
paradis fiscaux
la france a été en première ligne et à
contribuer à faire bouger l'europe et le
monde
mes chers compatriotes cet été de
retrouvailles et de retour aux sources
cet été qui sera fait de moments amicaux
et familiaux devra donc être néanmoins
été de vigilance de lutte contre le
virus de vaccination j'ai confiance en
vous confiance en nous pour rester unis
serein et déterminé alors à la rentrée
nous auront rendez vous avec notre
avenir pour bâtir une france
indépendante qui ne vit pas dans la
nostalgie mais c'est prendre les
décisions nécessaires à sa destinée une
france conquérante qui a foi en la force
de sa jeunesse et n'a pas peur du futur
mais l'un vante une france unie qui sait
être solidaire civique responsable dans
l'épreuve comme dans la conquête
vive la république et vive la france
[Musique]
voilà la locution d' emmanuel macron 27
minutes au total avec beaucoup
d'annonceurs ce soir en été de
mobilisation et de relance voilà comment
emmanuel macron qualifie les et
prochains mois cruciaux pour sortir le
pays de la crise sanitaire vaccination
obligatoire d'aidés soignants et autres
confessions au contact des gens les plus
fragiles extension du passani terre dès
le 21 juillet pour certaines catégories
août plus tard pour d'autres on verra ça
en détail contrôles aux frontières
renforcé avec comme objectif toujours
sortir de la dépendance et retrouver le
chemin de l'autonomie mais aussi
plusieurs grandes annonces concernant
notamment les grandes réformes voulues
par emmanuel macron du quinquennat
l'assurance maladie il compte bien la
mettre en application le chef de l'état
à partir du 1er octobre la réforme
explosive des retraites qui sera
nécessaire selon lui mais pas tant que
la crise épidémique sera maîtrisée
analyse et décryptage de cette
allocution avec nos invités tout de
suite
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler de cette
longue allocution riche en annonces
maxime thibeault docteur en droit public
éric bouchard médecin généraliste
président honoraire du syndicat des
médecins libéraux dans les
alpes-maritimes et enfin alexis poulain
éditorialistes bonsoir à tous les trois
merci messieurs d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france on va essayer de
décortiquer une par une
quasiment ces annonces avec notamment
luc allégé qui est en direct sur place
qui a suivi cette allocution mais avant
peut-être une petite première impression
de ces mesures maxime thibeault a
beaucoup d'annoncés effectivement qui
vont pas forcément faire plaisir à tous
les français ce soir on imagine oui
parce qu'on fait même si elle n'est pas
de droit la vaccination de
l'immobilisation de fait ils pourraient
pu prendre le train vous ne pouvez plus
à le restaurant vous ne pouvez plus on
fait de vivre la vie est terminée si
vous n'êtes pas vacciné
donc il faut bien comprendre ici que
malgré tout la logorrhée qu'on a pu
entendre
nous sommes passés à une vaccination
obligatoire des français qui pose
beaucoup de questions sur le plan de
l'éthique notamment parce que nous
sommes ici aussi dans une dans une
situation sanitaire qui fait la ned 6
nations reste sous une autorisation
d'autorisation de commandes de
vaccination qui est conditionnel pardon
il ya beaucoup de français qui utilisent
sont inquiets quant aux conséquences sur
le long terme et des différents vaccins
qui ne voulaient pas particulièrement
dans se faire vacciner parce que il
faisait la balance en langage risque et
cette balance il en revenait plutôt
positif quant à ne pas se faire vacciner
et ils sont malgré tout obligé en
pratiquement la corde au cou que d'aller
se faire vacciner je pense notamment aux
jeunes
quand on regarde en réalité les chiffres
font arrêter à n'importe quoi mais quand
on regarde les chiffres si les personnes
vulnérables et les personnes âgées sont
vaccinés les taux de spa ti
hospitalisation dans les pays où les
variants delta est arrivé dont augmenter
à partir du moment les personnes dont
qui était celle qui saturaient les
hôpitaux c'est à dire les personnes qui
ont des comorbidités et les personnes
âgées sont vaccinés vous n'avez plus de
saturation d'hôpitaux et donc le fait de
maxi
les plus jeunes les personnes qui sont
sans ou les personnes qui sont pas les
premiers concernés par la mortalité de
ce virus revient finalement simplement à
leurs obligés de l'acsi nation qui n'est
pas en réalité nécessaire pour hélas
apporte une véritable atteinte à la
liberté vaccinale et on verra ce que
dira le conseil constitutionnel suite au
vote de la loi qui doit intervenir fin
juillet mais je pense que tout cela
était préparée d'avancé que le parlement
sera suivie enfin écouter ses poulains
dans quelques instants que je sens déjà
bouillir je vois la fumée au dessus de
vos têtes alexis mais je vais d'abord
donner la parole aux médecins est ce que
vous êtes un médecin plutôt satisfait ce
soir on entend voilà les arguments du
juriste un de l'homme de droit on va
entendre une vie d'éditorialistes en
quelques instants mais vous le médecin
c'était nécessaire parce que on va aller
dans le détail mais c'est vrai qu'on
rend quasiment une vaccination
obligatoire en tout cas si on veut mener
une liste anti nenê normal il ya deux
choses d'abord concernant les soignants
il est évident que c'est quand même une
très bonne nouvelle pour les patients en
particulier savait qu'on a de nous des
gens tant que soignant des obligations
dont les médecins d éviter des
vaccinations obligatoires comme pour
l'hépatite b donc je dirais que c'est un
prime qui a vu normalement équipement
devrait on ne devrait même pas se poser
la question de savoir si en tant que
soignant ou d'être vaccinées ou non
ce qui est hallucinant est vraisemblable
c'est que encore 40% des soignants dans
les maisons dans les ehpad ne sont par
action donc je dirais qu'il ya quand
même un problème je rappelle qu'on a une
liberté comme ils disaient que mon
interlocuteur
d'ailleurs mes pneus aussi les
obligations là on a des choses à faire
on vit pas je dirais seul dans son coin
voilà il ya toute société il ya un
torrent qui existe parce qu'elle a
on peut aussi rouler tous à 250 euros
100 km sur autoroute s'occuper des
voisins non pour une fois de 13 à je
trouve que concernant la partie
vaccination des soignants c'est très
bien vous avez le droit de le pagne
d'accord avec moi je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec vous et je vous rappelle
que vous
l'hépatite b est une maladie qui tue des
blocs évidemment la personne dans les
rues la vaccination contre l'hépatite c
tu dénonces et supra qui m'a sorti
quant à l'expression l'on doit
absolument pas ici c'est parce qu'ils
sont complètement faux dans le détail de
ces mesures on voudrait on vend on va
entendre vos arguments en détail dans
quelques instants puisqu'on ils sont
très intéressants on va quand même
rapidement passer par alexis poulains
avant de retrouver le cas légers alexis
votre réaction ce soir
pour moi c'est ce soir un discours
extrêmement inquiétant presque délirant
dangereux et mal macron a prouvé qu'il
était le président de la violence dans
la façon qu'il a eue de gérer les
manifestations les mouvements des gilet
jaune avec une violence d'état
aujourd'hui la violence va plus loin
puisque c'est une obligation de vacciner
de se vacciner alors même que cette
obligation ne devait pas entrer dans les
textes puisque ce vaccin est en phase
test même si bien sûr on ne parle qu'une
phase test du produit une phase test de
l'efficacité de ce produit est
d'ailleurs l'efficacité pose question
puisque une troisième dose sera offerte
aux vacciner de la première heure
puisque visiblement ce vaccin ne suffit
pas il va falloir aller plus loin et
puis comme les variants vont arriver
encore et encore sans doute on aura des
doses trimestrielle voire mensuelle
puisque maintenant sur les comédies ont
apparemment des doses mensuel ferait des
miracles
alors il ya une vraie question
aujourd'hui est le maquereau demande aux
soignants d'être vaccinés les premiers
parce qu'ils sont au contact des
populations
il n'a dit aucun mot sur les policiers
qui sont également des métiers de
contact qui vont être eux qui vont
regarder les douaniers policiers qui
vont regarder si les passes sanitaires
sont efficaces dans les bars il est pas
sanitaires sont efficaces dans les
aéroports etc
bon pourquoi les policiers n'ont pas
obligation vaccinale est pourquoi
finalement on va pousser toutes les
classes de population sauf ceux là qui
vont organiser la répression
aujourd'hui ce qui se met en place avec
cette politique sanitaire c'est une
politique de répression une politique de
contrôle
c'est pas du tout politique sanitaire le
coc vide et je suis d'accord avec maxime
thibeault
terbi russe qui tue bien sûr c'est un
virus dangereux évidemment c'est un
virus qu'on ne connaît pas on ne sait
toujours pas d'où il vient comment il
s'est créé et qu'elles vont être ses
évolutions et bien sûr le risque c'est
qu'il évolue vers quelque chose de plus
grave
mais aujourd'hui nous avons des vaccins
efficace certes mais pas assez quand on
vaccine sur les onze vaccin obligatoire
des nouveau-nés évidemment qu'on le fait
puisqu'on a le recul suffisant et que
sans ça la polio reviendrai et d'autres
maladies encore plus grave donc oui les
vaccins sont une avancée formidable mais
ce produit de pfizer et ça me fait rire
parce qu'aujourd'hui on parle de vaccins
autorisés par l'autorité européenne du
médicament donc on parle de vaccins
américains allemands
mais quand il est question du vaccin
rusconi veille du vaccin chinois alors
là il ya plus personne et puis on dit
finalement à wind attendait les français
préparent à vaccin c'est pour plus tard
on verra on a pris beaucoup de retard
vous voyez on arrivera et mme emmanuel
macron nous parle ensuite de reprendre
notre souveraineté de reprendre la
fabrication notre pouvoir alors que nous
allons dépendre de vaccins étrangers
mais on est où en réalité qu'est ce que
c'est que ce discours moi ce soir j'ai
vu un discours extrêmement dangereux
extrêmement inquiétant ou derrière
finalement on avait d'ailleurs ces
mouvements de caméra c'est un exercice
de communication très orwélienne et mal
macron devant la tour eiffel comme une
seringue géante pour dire que allez vive
la france on va y aller mais nous
n'avons pas de vaccin france est donc
aujourd'hui si nous rentrons dans cette
stratégie vaccinale
nous allons dépendre de multinationales
qui ne sont pas françaises et qui vont
nous vendre des produits que nous allons
certes embouteillée sur notre territoire
mais que nous ne produisons pas
aujourd'hui je suis désolé on en
bouteille le kaiser on ne produit pas
donc ce soir j'ai vu un président qui
n'est pas du tout un président d'un pays
qui s'appelle la france mais quelqu'un
qui vend ce pays à la découpe et qui
obéit à des lobbys d'intérêts financiers
internationaux extrêmement important et
qui est là pour assurer ce profit
assurer une relance économique soit
disant de 6%
mais j'attends de voir un président des
français on va retrouver dans quelques
instants vous retrouvez un tous les
trois mais non on va faire un petit
détour justement vers l'elysée s'était
pas à l'elysée que emmanuel lacroix fait
ces annonces il n'empêche
lucas léger a tout de même suivi cette
locution lucas effectivement ce qui
retient l'attention ce soir ce qui va
certainement être le plus contraignant
aujourd'hui pour les français
cette extension du pass sanitaire que
peut-on retenir le cas
oui tout à fait et c'était la huitième à
dresde emmanuel macron aux français
aujourd'hui depuis le début de la crise
du coc u19 peut-être la plus importante
puisqu'elle est exprime et bien des
projets pour le long terme
il a même parlé évidemment de 2030 même
site et sur la partie économique donc
pour l'extension du pass sanitaires et
bien dès le 21 juillet pour les lieux de
culture et de loisirs à partir de 12 ans
puis ensuite et bien août avec l'aide
j'aime bien sûr des parlementaires pour
les restaurants les cafés c'était ce que
redoutaient les personnes qui ne
voulaient pas de cette vaccination
obligatoire je vous propose d'écouter
emmanuel macron dès le 21 juillet le
pass sanitaire sera étendue aux lieux de
loisirs et de culture
concrètement pour tous nos compatriotes
de plus de 12 ans il faudra pour accéder
à un spectacle un parc d'attractions un
concert ou un festival avoir été
vaccinés ou présenter un test négatif
récents ce pass est disponible sur
l'application tout senti qu vide mais
chacun peut utiliser la version papier
remise au moment de la vaccination à
partir du début du mois d'août le pass
sanitaire s'appliquera dans les cafés
les restaurants les centres commerciaux
ainsi que dans les hôpitaux les maisons
de retraite établissements médicaux
sociaux aussi dans les avions trains et
cars pour les longs trajets là encore
seuls les vaccinés et les personnes
testées négatives pourront accéder à ces
lieux qu'ils soient d'ailleurs clients
usagers ou salariés aujourd'hui seuls
50% des français de plus de 18 ans sont
vaccinés contre le coc vite 19 et le
conseil scientifique estime qu'il
faudrait de 90 à 95% des personnes qui
au mois soit le coc vide soit une
vaccination pour juguler l'épidémie
emmanuel macron a promis qu'il ne
rendrait pas la vaccination obligatoire
au cours de ces dernières allocutions
notamment en novembre puis sur le média
brut en décembre mais les mesures qu'il
s'apprête à prendre sont tellement
incitatives qu'on peut se demander si ça
ne revient pas de fer a obligé et bien
cette négociation merci le cas légers on
trouve nos trois invités
maxime thibeault éric bouchard et alexis
poulain effectivement maxime thibon on
en parlait à moins de rester enfermé
chez soi il faudra clairement se faire
vacciner si on veut mener une vie
normale
y compris chez les mineurs puisque c'est
à partir de plus de 12 ans la france est
clairement précurseur en la matière
beaucoup d'autres pays européens n'ont
pas osé encore franchir ce pas est ce
que ça pose des problèmes clairement de
droit mais bien sûr mais bien sûr que ça
pose un gros problème de droit car on
entend tous les émotifs
vous savez tous les médecins qui ont les
plateaux télé mes combats je plus jamais
dans leurs cabinets médicaux nous dire
la vaccination se fait bien vacciné
contre d'autres maladies bien plus grave
et oui les maladies qui tuent réellement
des maladies ou si vous la trempe et
vous avez 80 % de mortalité peut-être 10
% de mortalité
là le kobe de 19 c'est une maladie qui
tue moins 2% de la population qui nous
concerne en réalité pour les personnes
âgées ou les personnes qui ont des
comorbidités c'est une maladie dont la
vaccination finalement n'est
pratiquement d'intérêt que pour les
personnes qui risque d'en mourir
certains malades c'est à dire une
personne malade ou des personnes âgées
et là on va obliger des gens sont des
gens qui n'ont aucun risque pour eux
même ou pour autrui à avoir le l'accent
si les personnes vulnérables sont
d'accès mais bien sûr à être vaccinés
mais c'est une attaque est complètement
liberticide
c'est sans précédent dans notre histoire
la liberté d'aller et venir la liberté
d'aller dans des commerces la liberté
culturelle la liberté même ponctuelle
d'être limité à l'obligation de se faire
vacciner mais je ne sais pas si on se
rend compte aujourd'hui des conséquences
pour nos libertés fondamentales que le
président macron a eu ce soir ils nous
avaient annoncé qu'ils ne rendraient pas
la vaccination obligatoire
pourquoi parce qu'il savait très bien
qu'elle n'était pas efficace pour une
partie de la population qui n'a pas être
vaccinés parce que à partir du moment où
les gens qui saturent les hôpitaux les
hôpitaux le sont bas il ya plus de
problèmes au jour
8 quand vous regardez le variant delta
en grande bretagne vous remarquez une
chose assez simple c'est que certes le
taux d'incidence augmente mais en fait
le tour de spécialisation dans devant
moi parce que les personnes vulnérables
et personnes âgées sont vaccinés c'est
la même chose enfants vous aider chez
nos confrères du figaro des des
graphiques qui était très très clair
vous avez des l'augmentation du taux
d'incidence mais vous aviez pas une
augmentation du closeau statines
hôpitalisation et on va voir ça sur le
mois de juillet le mois d'août
donc en fait et je suis d'accord avec ce
que disait monsieur prix nous sommes en
fait dans un système très en rejoignant
ou monsieur macron répond à des intérêts
sur la vaccination nous parle de
troisième dose en fait on nous parle sur
les prochaines années d'une date six
nations qui sera récurrente chronique
obligatoire chaque année avec la parole
du médecin parce que les français font
confiance à leur médecin qui je pense
est beaucoup craignent le serment
d'hippocrate ces derniers temps parce
que notamment les a jamais entendus sur
les traitements alors qu elles ces
derniers ont plutôt fait preuve
d'efficacité dans des pays comme en en
inde
donc je me méfie beaucoup des médecins
de plateau en ce moment et on va voir
comme ça son greffon un système donné la
parole à l'un d'entre eux maxime
thibeault justement parce que c'est
intéressant parce que ce que vous nous
dites évidemment de nombreux français
certainement le pense ce soir devant
leur télévision ou la radio
éric bouchard a ses arguments c'est une
maladie qui peut tu très peu notamment
les plus fragiles important de la
population et d'une certaine manière ce
soir on rend la vaccination quasi
obligatoire pour les français en tout
cas qui ont un tout petit peu envie de
sortir de chez eux qu est ce que vous
nous répondez quels sont les arguments
médicaux sont pleines 60 quelques
statistiques qui sont parus dernièrement
l'europe a perdu 300 mille trois cent
mille personnes
il en 2020 c'est à dire que via donc
trois cent mille décès de plus qui ont
qui sont arrivés ça ne tient pas compte
bien entendu qu'ils ont certainement un
petit peu plus élevé puisque on a eu
quand même une arrivée en immigration
alors concernant la vaccination je pense
que l'eau on oubliait vous n'oubliez
quelque chose dans les points démis pour
faire un peu d'histoire des pandémies de
temps en temps il faut regarder toutes
les pandémies elle dure en moyenne deux
ans avec en moyenne trois à quatre
vagues et au jura ne s'arrête elle sera
quasiment tout seul
pourquoi parce que il n'ya plus le virus
le plus
plus transmettre parce que les gens
meurent je rappelle que la teste pour
donner un petit peu d'histoire
au moyen-âge et en particulier en
grande-bretagne
on avait vu tellement de morts qu'on
avait il y avait plus suffisamment de
vivant pour réussir enterrer les morts
donc en fait le problème de fond est
assez simple pour qu'une pandémie
s'arrête et qu'un virus comme une arête
débuté puisque c'est toujours un peu
d'inquiétude
il faut qu'on a de le transmettre c'est
quelque chose que je pense que tout le
monde peut comprendre qu'il n'y a pas
besoin d'avoir d'avoir fait sciences po
pour le faire ou même médecine donc
comment est ce qu'on fait on a
actuellement un prêt de transmission la
transmission elle se passe d'homme à
homme
elle est le virus certains virus sont
plusieurs langues dont c'est le cap du
delta donc on va faire simple il faut
arrêter de transmettre pour atteindre
transmettre via les mesures barrières on
a tous un peu marre je dirais il ya le
confinement ça n'a rien de très
passionnant et là je pense que là par
contre qui a eu quand même une atteinte
à nos libertés qui autrement plus
importante que celle d'obliger les
soignants à se faire vacciner
qui pour moi après mme durement éthiques
j'imagine je retire comme ça mais ça je
partage pas votre avis ces points de vue
de beaucoup de médecins de mes confrères
il ya un premier clip vous avez vous
rigolez ça change pas le problème en la
matière il ya des choses qui doivent
être faites par les professionnels de
santé au sens large c'est quelque chose
de normal
après je dirais concernant la place
sanitaires j'ai un avis mitigé le
suivaient leurs données je reconnais que
je suis un ex sur le moniteur agréé
cette affaire-là j'ai pas encore ce que
je vous ai laissé de barney vous
pourriez laisser parler je sais que
damian cantine à coups de pétitions tous
assez bavard donc on avait mal à la
voilà on a le sentiment d'un alexis
poule a en tout cas il ya une chose qui
va vous faire sourire de manière très
ironique 17000 rendez vous pris toutes
les minutes sur des collines depuis la
locution des mesnel macron ça a donc
fonctionné mais évidemment que ça
fonctionne l'idée c'est de refourguer
tout ce qu'il reste de vaccins en disant
allez ici vous pouvez si vous hésitez
n'hésitez pas il faut le faire et puis
vous aurez ensuite l'ouverture de la
3ème de la 4e et puis dès que vous
voulez et puis il faut faire confiance à
ce vaccin après tout puisqu'il
fonctionne effectivement en terme de
près de 2 de protection face à des
formes graves ça marche mais très peu de
gens encore une fois développent des
formes graves et puis après c'est
surtout sur la la contagion 12 fois loin
de contagion si vous êtes vacciné donc
c'est en ça que ce vaccin est une chance
pour l'économie pour la relance de
l'économie
mais quand le pass sanitaire va être mis
en place attention moi j'aurai une
question à la personne qui me demandera
mon pass sanitaire je lui demanderai
simplement si les vaccinés et de montrer
également son pass sanitaire parce que
c'est quoi ce bordel
excusez moi du terme on est en train de
faire que des restaurateurs des gens qui
sont des commerçants vont devenir des
capots vont devenir des gens qui vous
vous demandez si vous avez le droit de
rentrer chez eux mais on est où si ces
gens-là accepte ce monde là alors ils
seront prêts à accepter le pire après ça
parce que là on est souvent une question
très simple je veux bien qu'on en ait
marre du masque je veux bien qu'on vend
des masques de marc du gel etc
mais quand on aura des vaccins
trimestriels on en aura peut-être marre
aussi finalement de se dire mais
attendez je n'avais pas signé pour ça et
on vous dira oui mais vous savez le coc
vite ça évolue on en est à l'oméga
maintenant alors vous comprenez on a
fait toutes les lettres de l'alphabet
grec va passer maintenant sur des
symboles égyptien donc comprenez qu'il
faut continuer un moment ça suffit en
fait de lever les uns contre les autres
de faire que les non vaccinés sont les
ennemis des vaccinés de fer que certains
n'auraient pas le droit
les mêmes droits que d'autres citoyens
parce qu'ils ont choisi finalement de ne
pas prendre un produit qui n'a pas
encore fait toutes ses preuves alors
certains les études le disent des études
qui sont encore une fois financé par
ceux là qui vendent ces vaccins moi je
suis pas anti vaccins je pense que c'est
une avancée phénoménale sur ce qu vide
la rapidité de ses sérum la façon tout
ça a été géré me pose question et
devrait poser question à tout le monde
et la violence avec lesquels ceux qui
veulent vacciner à tout prix tout le
monde et maîtres maintenant à la
vindicte populaire des non vaccinés
devrait aussi nous poser question et
puis ensuite ce modèle de société ou des
restaurateurs ou des commerçants
devraient redevenir des policiers des
capots devrait aussi nous pose des
questions je suis désolé ce n'est plus
la démocratie ce n'est plus une société
libérale
nous sommes en train de rentrer dans un
modèle à la chinoise de citoyenneté
avéré si l'état vous a dit de faire ça
et que vous la vaisselle alors vous avez
tous les droits
si vous avez ou contraire ne pas vous
avez pas accepter finalement ce qu'a dit
l'état alors
c'est un mauvais citoyen ou honte à vous
vous n'aurez droit à rien et si les
français acceptent ça alors je crois que
le xxième siècle sera très compliqué en
france et en europe
maxime thibeault à vous qui voilà qui
est vent debout contre ces pass
sanitaires quand on ferme des
restaurants sur des lieux de vacances
parce qu'il ya des clusters ça arrive en
ce moment en corse un par exemple qu'est
ce qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on fait dans
ces cas là on ne ferme pas du tout les
restaurants ou alors effectivement les
personnes qui se sont vaccinés pâtissent
de ces clusters peut-être de la part de
gens non vacciné je vous pose la
question parce que c'est aussi un
argument qu'on entend de la part des
gens qui sont plutôt pro vaccination
donc c'est bien d'avoir les deux sons de
cloche mais j'ai eu la preuve d'une
contamination dé d'un cluster dans des
restaurants devant le conseil d'état le
gouvernement n'a jamais été capable d'en
apporter la preuve
moi je ne lis que les conclusions qui
sont faits par les conseillers d'état
dans les différentes mesures dans les
différentes ordonnances twitter des
saisines en référé on se rend compte
qu'en soit tout sur le conditionnel en
permanence est ainsi diop et intuitive
et ça comme vous voulez faites sur des
plages jamais arrivé on n'est jamais
arrivé à démontrer ou circulaires
réellement le virus à part dire c'est
dans les lieux clos ça s'arrête là mais
on n'a jamais pu le démontrer
moi je ne vois qu'une seule chose je
suis un peu d aller si on faisait un peu
droit comparé au niveau international on
a été l'un des rares pays en europe à
avoir un coup reçu aussi longtemps à
avoir un confinement si longtemps avoir
une fermeture des restaurants des lieux
culture aussi longtemps on est l'un des
premiers pays au monde à avoir
l'obligation vaccinale pour l'ensemble
des français
art de facto juste en automne mais de
droits à partir du mois d'août à partir
les mois d'octobre novembre donc
donc on n'est plus un pays libéral à la
personne qui me dit aujourd'hui je c'est
un pays libéral elle ne sait pas ce
qu'est un état libéral et la sécurité
n'est pas la première des libertés
l'ordre public il n'intervient il doit
être finalement on doit mettre fin au
trouble à l'ordre public
lorsqu'il sa mère qui les disent des
mesures qui ont fait la preuve qu'elles
sont efficaces pour établir cet ordre
public
cet ordre sanitaires on se rend compte
que la vaccination c'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga
face à ce problème sanitaire il faut
lutter contre les comorbidités il faut
avoir peut-être des solutions via les
traitements il faut réfléchir à réouvrir
des places d'hospitalisation
il faut penser à la vaccination des
personnes vulnérables et des personnes
âgées et faire preuve de pédagogie vers
ces personnes parce que c'est là qu'on
voit qui a le plus haut taux de
mortalité mais obligé l'ensemble de la
population française à se faire vacciner
alors que cela n'a aucune efficacité et
en plus ce mythe et les français les uns
contre les autres du politique qui
relève davantage du machiavélisme que de
la politique sanitaire
éric bouchard le mot de la fin pour vous
ce pas de sanitaires est ce qu'il est
vraiment efficace on se rappelle que ces
fameux supporters écossais sont revenus
avec le co vide alors même que qu'ils
avaient un pass annie terre qu'ils ont
présentée avant de rentrer dans ce stade
de l'euro est ce que c'est vraiment ce
qu'il fallait faire il ya deux j'ai deux
points de vue là-dessus je pense que
d'abord il va être difficilement
faisable et je pense que les deux
interlocuteurs à expliquer les problèmes
je vois pas restaurateur d'amendé le
pass alité systématiquement ça va être
compliqué même si dans la théorie on
peut l'avoir avec soi la vaccination
soit éventuellement avec un test pcr
négatif
néanmoins d'autres spécialités elle
existe déjà
si vous voulez n'en reste actuellement
vous avez besoin du passage du ter ils
ont en janvier à maintenant quelque
chose qui s'appelle le plf
hormis je pense que je ne sais plus très
bien pop correspond cette année
chronique vous êtes obligés d'envoyer
votre certificat de vaccination pas
l'état grec ou créent donc vous
remplissiez tout ça il vous autorise à
venir donc on est déjà dans cette
problématique là et donc la liberté elle
est déjà très limité elle se limiter là
dessus c'est vrai que je serai un peu
comme hall d'un pas trop que ma liberté
sur l'unité en la matière mais je pense
que ça passe sanitaires si on on
n'abandonne pas être d'accord j'ai
entendu beaucoup de bêtises mais j'ai
entendu des choses quand ils sortent
et donc je pense que premièrement en
force demandé à des restaurateurs ou
d'autres de vérifier ça me paraît
impossible techniquement j'ai pas
comment ça va être possible
donc je pense qu'il faut faire attention
aux mesures que l'on que l'on prend moi
je reste sur la seule mesure qui moi me
paraît être la plus judicieuse
actuellement et petits plombs la plus
cohérente celle à l'obligation pour les
professionnels de santé
je reste dessus je suis très clair après
il y avait lu je crois qu'il y avait il
y avait donc le pcr payant on en a pas
trop parlé j'ai pas non plus un avis
spéciale je dirais que c'est peut-être
pas nécessaire non plus rue ni la
sécurité sociale aidant catholique tous
les cinq minutes en la matière enfin
terminé on a au moins un point unique et
commun avec ces deux ans nos deux autres
interlocuteurs beaucoup d'interrogations
sur le pass sanitaires et un point de
vue très différents
je pense que les professions de santé de
golf se faire vacciner voilà ça serait
pour moi le mot de la fin
rayé le mot de la fin on va aussi un le
consacrer à d'autres annonces ou combien
importantes qui vont peut-être
certainement modifier la rentrée en
puisque emmanuel macron est revenu sur
la nécessité de plusieurs réformes dont
celle de l'assurance chômage à partir du
1er octobre la réforme des retraites fin
des régimes spéciaux recul de l'âge
légal de la retraite qui sera nécessaire
pas avant que l'épidémie soit sous
contrôle
un petit mot terme pour terminer alexis
poulain sur ac annonce pour le moins
explosif dans les mois qui viennent oui
on voit bien qu'on est typiquement dans
la stratégie du choc un telle qu'elle a
été expliqué on profite d'une crise pour
en faire une opportunité et faire passer
des mesures qui ne seraient jamais
passés en temps normal et emmanuel
macron très clairement attendu la fin de
son allocution pour l'air de rien dire
que finalement oui il fera ses mesures
si la crise sanitaire est jugulée bien
entendu et qu' il faudra de toute façon
les faire qu'il n'y a pas d'autre choix
il a maintenant quelques mois devant lui
pour finir ce qu'il a commencé
c'est-à-dire vendre à la découpe achevé
le système social français alors même
qu'il se défend de d'être là pour le
protéger pour le pérenniser
c'est scandaleux
fait partie également de cette
manipulation permanente qui a été la
marque de ce quinquennat de la violence
aussi qui a été la marque de ce
quinquennat
ce soir ce discours moi m'a effrayée
j'espère qu'il a effrayé de nombreux
français parce que ce qui se profile si
jamais malema qu'on devait être réélu
et bien c'est tout sauf une démocratie
libérale comme maxime thibault vient de
le dire et je crois que nous devons être
vigilants parce que les contre pouvoirs
sont faibles aujourd'hui en france et
parce que le débat démocratique n'existe
pas quand il dit que nous avons
collectivement fait des choix non il a
choisi seul lors des conseils de défense
les confinements ou non maintenant il a
choisi seul lors du conseil de dépenses
de ce matin la vaccination quasiment
obligatoire avec le pass annie terre
partout ce n'est pas démocratique
le conseil d'état malheureusement elle
est bien seul tout comme le conseil
constitionnel pour essayer de limiter
les dégâts
mais en réalité le peuple et en dehors
de l'équation le peuple français lui
n'est jamais consulté sur ces grands
orientations qui vont vous emmener très
loin des rives de la démocratie libérale
merci en tout cas tous les 3 maxime
thiébaut éric bouchard alexis apoula
merci d'avoir débriefer donc cette
allocution d' emmanuel macron ce soit
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
justement sur ces annonces ont le
président qui a annoncé la vaccination
obligatoire pour le personnel de santé
extension également du pass and i ter et
puis nous évoquerons ensuite la
rencontre aux etats-unis entrepreneurs
et les autorités sanitaires américaines
face à l'émergence du variant delta
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer cinq ans de psychodrame
ça qu'on négociations politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête le 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre vab un perdreau là nos amis
britanniques ont fait un choix en 2016
qui est un choix qui je pense va
impacter l'économie profondément sur les
prochaines années et va impacter des
générations les choses sont en train de
se caler de se mettre en place
est ce que les choses sont totalement
fluide réponse est non
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois il n'y a pas une façon plus
pauvres de défendre un système que de
dire qu'il est moins pire qu'un autre le
peuple c'était une volonté collectés
vous le savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative au sort du
pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses
les chiffres qui sont avancés qui sont
montrés aux salariés et à leurs
représentants sont des chiffres en
décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de dissiper cet écran de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise et fiable mais
comment peuvent-ils mentir comme des
arracheurs de dents à ce point
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous 21h merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les types de
l'actualité de ce lundi 12 juillet un
été de mobilisation et de relance voilà
comment emmanuel macron qualifie les
prochains mois cruciaux pour sortir de
le pays de la crise sanitaire
vaccination obligatoire des soignants
expansion du pad sanitaire de le 21
juillet contrôles aux frontières
renforcé avec comme objectif sortir de
la dépendance et retrouver le chemin de
l'autonomie mais aussi de nombreuses
annonces concernant les réformes comme
l'assurance chômage et celle des
retraites qui sera nécessaire selon le
chef de l'état la progression du variant
delta au coeur d'une allocution donc d'
emmanuel macron et son émergence qui
inquiète également outre atlantique les
états unis se préparent à prendre des
mesures pour maîtriser sa progression ce
lundi les autorités sanitaires
américaines reçoivent les représentants
de pfizer ont vu la possible mise en
place dans les mois à venir d'une
troisième dose de sexe
une rencontre pour discuter des enjeux
planétaires john kerry et l'envoyé
spécial chargé de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique s'entretenait
aujourd'hui avec sergueï lavrov chef de
la diplomatie russe
au programme la coopération thématiques
entre deux des plus grands émetteurs de
co2 du globe à moins de quatre mois de
la conférence des nations unies de
novembre prochain qui se tiendra à
glasgow
[Musique]
insuffler un nouvel élan voilà le
leitmotiv du nouveau gouvernement de
pedro sanchez mi mandat le premier
ministre socialiste espagnol annonce un
remaniement qui rajeunit et fut mini son
cabinet minoritaire
une nouvelle équipe pour un exécutif qui
une fois le plus dur de la pandémie
surmonter devra oeuvrer à la reprise
économique et à la création d'emplois
[Musique]
une allocution présidentielle attendue
donc alors que le variant delta menace
de gâcher l'été le message est clair
pour faire face à l'épidémie d'exécutive
passe à la vitesse supérieure
vaccination obligatoire des soignants
passe sanitaire contrôles aux frontières
emmanuel macron aussi abordé la question
des grandes réformes de la fin de son
quinquennat
retour sur cette allocution avec notre
reporter lucas léger bonsoir du cas vous
avez donc suivi l'allocution des
bagnoles macron que faut-il en retenir
eh bien le président s'exprimait donc
pour la huitième fois dans une adresse
officielle aux français depuis le début
est bien de cette crise du coc vite 19
il a commencé par remercier les français
pour leurs efforts consentis au cours de
ces longs mois de pandémie ces longs
mois de privation pour lui il y a une
solution pour sortir de cela c'est la
vaccination et à commencer par la
vaccination des personnes qui sont au
contact de ceux qui sont les plus
vulnérables c'est pourquoi il annoncé ce
qui n'était pas vraiment une surprise
puisque ça avait été largement préparé à
l'avancé et bien la vaccination du
personnel soignant et de des personnes
qui sont en contact avec les personnes
vulnérables
ils auront jusqu'au 15 septembre pour se
faire vacciner après cela il y aura des
contrôles et le président a même évoqué
d'éventuelles sanctions je vous propose
de l'écouter sur le point précis de la
vaccination du personnel soignant
dans un premier temps pour les
personnels soignants et non soignants
des hôpitaux des cliniques des maisons
de retraite des établissements pour
personnes en situation de handicap pour
tous les professionnels ou bénévoles qui
travaillent au contact des personnes
âgées ou fragiles y compris à domicile
la vaccination sera rendue obligatoire
sans attendre
j'ai conscience de ce que je vous
demande
je sais que vous êtes prêts à cet
engagement cela participe ou quelque
sorte de votre sens du devoir pour tous
nos compatriotes concernés ils auront
jusqu'au 15 septembre pour se faire
vacciner
il faut commencer dès maintenant à
partir du 15 septembre des contrôles
seront opérés et des sanctions seront
prises
le président n'a pas exclu de rendre la
vaccination
obligatoire mais il avait avant précisé
qu'il ne voulait pas le faire c'est
pourquoi il mise actuellement sur
l'extension du pass sanitaires pour
inciter un maximum de français est bien
à se faire vacciner c'est toujours
l'horizon annoncé la vaccination pour
sortir de la crise c'est pourquoi à
partir de juillet à partir de 12 ans et
à partir de juillet les lieux de culture
et de loisirs seront soumis à l'entrée
donc du pass sanitaires et après en août
pour les cafés et restaurants avec
l'aide des parlementaires je vous
propose d'écouter emmanuel macron sur
l'extension du pass salita dès le 21
juillet le pass sanitaire sera étendue
aux lieux de loisirs et de culture
concrètement pour tous nos compatriotes
de plus de 12 ans il faudra pour accéder
à un spectacle un parc d'attractions un
concert ou un festival avoir été
vaccinés ou présenter un test négatif
récents ce pass est disponible sur
l'application tout senti qu vide mais
chacun peut utiliser la version papier
remise au moment de la vaccination à
partir du début du mois d'août le pass
sanitaire s'appliquera dans les cafés
les restaurants les centres commerciaux
ainsi que dans les hôpitaux les maisons
de retraite établissements médicaux
sociaux mais aussi dans les avions
trains et cars pour les longs trajets là
encore seuls les vaccinés et les
personnes testées négatives pourront
accéder à ces lieux qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs clients usagers ou salariés
le président mise sur septembre pour
reprendre sa politique ses grandeurs
réforme avant la fin du quinquennat
notamment la mère des réformes de la
macro ni la réforme des retraites qui
prévoit notamment la suppression des
quarante deux régimes spéciaux de
retraite pour le remplacer par un
système universel à point on sait que ça
avait littéralement occuper le débat
public avant le coc vie de 19 notamment
en 2019 et début 2000 20 avec une grève
trade
difficile par les syndicats le président
avait annoncé qu'il suspendait cette
réforme
le 16 mars 2020 je vous propose
d'écouter le président sur le retour est
bien de ses réformes
nous devrons engager dès que les
conditions sanitaires seront réunies la
réforme des retraites
j'ai toujours tenu un langage de vérité
oui notre système est injuste
avec quarante deux régimes différents il
entretient des inégalités majeur et il
faudra aller vers plus de simplicité
pour plus de justice et donc les régimes
spéciaux devront être supprimés pour les
nouveaux employés dans ces secteurs
oui parce que nous vivons plus longtemps
il nous faudra travailler plus longtemps
et partir à la retraite plus tard pas
demain pas brutalement pas de manière
uniforme car il faut prendre en compte
la difficulté des métiers mais
progressivement sur plusieurs années et
par un système qui fait la différence
selon le travail réellement exercer une
vie de travail doit offrir une pension
digne et donc toute retraite pour une
carrière complète devra être supérieure
à 1000 euros par mois voilà ce que je
vous l'avais entendu le président a
évoqué un allongement de la durée du
travail et ça eh bien c'est contraire à
ses promesses de campagne et ça pose
peut-être certains problèmes au sein de
la majorité c'est pourquoi sans doute
aujourd'hui il a après cette allocution
résolu de rencontrer les parlementaires
de la majorité
ici à l'elysée il y en a plusieurs qui
se sont retrouvés autour de nous nous
avons notamment vu thierry solère et il
ce groupe donc de la majorité a été
largement érodé notamment par la défaite
du parti présidentiel aux dernières
élections puis à celle d'avant pour les
municipales merci lui calé j'ai
évidemment le président macro qui a
également évoqué plusieurs réformes 1 de
la fin de son quinquennat
l'assurance maladie
il souhaite mener à bien ce texte 1er
octobre et la réforme des retraites
une nécessité selon le chef de l'état
qui a évoqué une augmentation de l'âge
légal de la retraite notamment une
réforme qui sera mené à bien
quand la crise sanitaire sera maîtrisée
at il précisé parlant également de la
fin des régimes spéciaux de retraite et
pour parler de cette allocution du chef
de l'état nous sommes avec gilbert
collard député européen est reine
bonsoir gilbert collard merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france une
première réaction à ces annonces des
manuels macron notamment le pass
sanitaire qui va rendre la vie vraiment
extrêmement compliqué à tous les non
vaccinés en france goûtez moi je
voudrais que les choses soient claires
parce que nous avons besoin du courage
de la carte et je ne suis absolument pas
contre les vaccins
je ne suis ni pour ni contre le vaccin
contre le virus
mais je pense que chacun devrait avoir
le droit d'option et je considère que
d'oubli j'ai la population à se faire
vacciner ce qui devient inévitable
compte tenu du passeport sanitaire qui
est mis en place constitue une atteinte
à la liberté de disposer de son propre
corps et je trouve que ce n'est pas
normal
encore une fois chacun est libre de
faire ce qu'il veut je ne dis pas qu'il
ne faut pas se faire vacciner moi je ne
dis pas non plus que il faut se faire
vacciner sous peine d'être considéré
comme le dit monsieur kouchner comme un
traître ou rendez compte on en est bon
je dis que chacun devrait dans le
respect des gestes barrières dans la
prudence faire comme il l'entend et je
trouve que la manière dont s'instaure 7
cette dictature
vaccinale 1 puisque si on n'est pas
vacciné on pourra plus sortir de chez
soi donc ça veut dire que il faut se
faire vacciner par contrainte et tous
les gens qui comme moi sont obligés de
se déplacer comment pourrait-il ne pas
se faire vacciner alors même que alors
même que c'est un point important si
vous le permettez une autorisation de
mise sur le marché de ces vaccins et
conditionnel et qu' on en est encore en
essais cliniques de la phase iii ou iv
alors là la contrepartie qu on devrait
exiger pour cette vaccination
obligatoire c'est que l'union européenne
rende publics les contrats qui lient
l'union au laboratoire que chaque
citoyen sache dans quelle condition le
produit qu'on va de contraintes lui
injecter a été achetée négocier
existe-t-il des clauses
d'irresponsabilité y at il des clauses
de sauvegarde enfin voilà là il y aurait
une contrepartie quand même qui serait à
mon avis indispensable et qu'on doit
exiger que les que les démocrates
doivent exiger maintenant encore une
fois je voudrais absolument pas que
cette querelle sur la vaccination
devienne un fruit de discorde entre
français parce que la peine non les gens
commencent à s'opposer d'une manière
irrationnelle
il ya ceux qui sont pour le vaccin ceux
qui sont contre le vaccin et ça va finir
par une empoignade ça et finalement
quand on écoute quand on écoute le seul
accroc
on devrait être conclue ce là dessus si
vous permettez lui rappeler ce que
disait monsieur dupont moretti vous
savez le ministre de la justice
quand il était question de vacciner
obligatoirement les prisonniers ils
disaient les détenus ne sont pas des
cobayes
on ne vaccine rappaz de force
ah bon les détenus ne sont pas des
cobayes mais ce qu'ils ne sont pas
détenus sont maintenant en détention
sanitaires bon il ferait bien de
réfléchir
le président de la république à ce que
disait son ministre de la justice
aujourd'hui clairement vous êtes avocat
avant tout gilbert collard est ce que ça
pose comme nous le disaient nos invités
précédent 1 maxime thibeault notamment
docteur en droit public les des
problèmes tout simplement sur le plan de
la légalité une forme de vaccination
obligatoire sans la nommer sachant
qu'elle est vraiment en revanche pour
les soignants on va vous dire c'est
l'éternel argument mais il ya des
vaccins qui ont été rendus obligatoires
c'est vrai mais ce sont des vaccins qui
avait une antériorité que l'on avait mis
des années et des années et des années à
mettre au point et qui avait quand même
été testé et il y avait là la sécurité
du temps écoulé alors est ce qu'on
pourra recourir devant des juridictions
comme le tribunal administratif le
conseil d'état le conseil
constitutionnel bien sûr espérons qu'ils
se lèveront un gardien de nos libertés
d'autant que rappelez vous ces vaccins
n'agissent pas sur les variants alors
ils diminuent c'est vrai semble-t-il en
ce qui concerne le vit lui de le virus
premier il diminue l'effet de la maladie
semble t-il
mais il est vite passé pardonnez-moi
indiqué que c'est tous les vaccins sur
le marché français était aujourd'hui
efficace contre les variants c'est ce
qu'il a dit en début de nos pulsions
oui le feuillet plein d'études qui
disent le contraire alors là bon moi je
vais pas me je n'ai pas la compétence
qui me permettrait de discuter de la
question médicale mais je suis un simple
électeur et je lis des habits très très
contraire très différents bon il ya
plein de spécialistes qui disent que
c'est pas efficace sur les variants qui
il ya même le professeur pire aux morts
qui a indiqué que ça pouvait avoir un
effet sur les variants le vaccin bon
d'ogone et dans une incertitude pendant
personne ne peut avoir la prétention de
détenir la vérité
mais au moins le doute devrait
bénéficier aux vaccinés qui ne veut pas
l'être en tout cas
si emmanuel macron avec une
arrière-pensée d'ailleurs elle ne s'en
cache pas objectif vaccination 17000
rendez-vous a pris toutes les minutes
sur le site d'octo libre ainsi qui a
fini par être tout simplement planté à
l'heure qu'il est il est plus possible
de prendre aucun rendez vous c'était
finalement une bonne stratégie si on
voulait penser à la vaccination
aujourd'hui
oui mais si tu sais si c'est la
stratégie du père fouettard qui ne va
pas forcément contenter les fautes et
les gens se sont dit comme beaucoup
d'amis à moi à bas et que si on va aller
au café si on va aller au restaurant
si on veut prendre le train vous rendez
compte si si le 1 1 car il faut qu'on
soit vacciné 6 ou alors il faut qu'on
aille faire un test avec toutes les
complications de d'emploi du temps que
cela représente donc les les gens sont
allés pour ne pas être trop emmerder se
faire vacciner je les comprends et je
les comprends je ne les je ne les juge
pas je ne les condamne pas je les
comprends mais je trouve que le temps
dira où est la vérité du reste le temps
le dira la hyène
il ya une il ya un verdict auquel
personne n'échappera dans cette triste
affaire de la pandémie
c'est le temps le temps sera un juge
effroyable pour ceux qui ont pris des
décisions bonnes ou mauvaises
alors une fois que la pandémie sera
maîtrisée apparemment plusieurs réformes
vont être appliquées c'était l'une des
grandes annonces de la soirée également
l'assurance maladie ça ce sera
l'assurance pardon chômage assez décrié
ce sera à partir du 1er octobre suivi
donc de la réforme des retraites par la
nécessité de pousser l'âge légal de la
retraite la fin des régimes spéciaux une
réaction la réforme des retraites si
j'ai bien compris
tant que la pandémie sera là la réforme
ne sera pas tout à fait voilà mais le
mais si on a l'impression
veut pas être désobligeant mais que le
président de la république était un peu
un voyageur de commerce des mots avec
tous ces mots valises dans lesquels il y
a il n'y a rien il n'y a rien car
comment va-t-il financer quand il nous
dit cela ne coûtera rien mais il se
moque du monde il se moque du monde bon
et il est à dix mois de l'élection il
découvre maintenant que l'insécurité
sévit que la situation économique est
dramatique au passage quand il a parlé
de la sécurité ne croyez vous pas qu'il
aurait pu avoir un mot pour ce jeune
théo 18 ans assassinée par un
ressortissant étranger qui était non pas
en situation régulière mais dans le
titre de séjour expiré dans quelques
mois et qui avait été longuement
condamné déjà y aurait pu avoir un mot
non mais il a même pas eu voiliers et ça
je lui reproche
merci en tout cas gilbert collard
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre réaction après l'allocution
d'emmanuel macron situations de plus en
plus inquiétante en tunisie deux pays
enregistre chaque jour un nouveau
chiffre record de décès la campagne
vaccinale peine à décoller et le pays a
lancé un appel aux dons notamment en
matière d'appareils de respiration
artificielle pour plus de précisions
retrouve notre correspondant à tunis ben
hassen chébili bonsoir bassem la
situation donc est de plus en plus
occupante avec un record hier de
contamination et daudet c'est
effectivement stéphanie bonsoir la
situation est de plus en plus dramatique
est inquiétante
ici en tunisie la tunisie qui lie sa
quatrième vague il semble complètement
débordées notamment en termes de vaccins
en termes de médicaments musiciens en
termes d'équipement depuis le début de
la pandémie due coronavirus jamais le
ministère de la santé avait enregistré
autant de décès par jour samedi on a
enregistré le chiffre de 195 décès par
jour ce qui est un record plus de 9000
contamination journalières le système de
santé est complètement à l'abandon le
personnel de santé qui demandent au
gouvernement de prendre des mesures
radicales pour laurent venir en aide
un manque de matériel manque de
personnel mais aussi manque deux
respirateurs énormément deux personnels
soignants ont déclaré être au bout du
rouleau être fatigués surtout être
abandonnées des hôpitaux saturent on
arrive sur certaines régions où il ya
plus de places en réanimation malgré le
couvre-feu qui est toujours maintenue
sur l'ensemble du territoire
malgré certains gouvernorats qu'ils ont
complètement confiner le gouvernement a
pris certaines mesures notamment
l'interdiction de circuler de sortir
tous les week-ends dans le grand tunis
ou encore d'interdire la circulation
entre les régions objectif essayer de
canaliser cette nombre importants de
contamination qu'enregistre la tunisie
jour après jour et bassem le système
dont deux de santé un tunisien l'agonie
alors que le personnel soignant lui
demandent de l'aide en urgence et que le
gouvernement multiplie les appels aux
dons et la campagne de vaccination cléty
effectivement c'est fini c'est à partir
de ce cri d alerte du personnel soignant
un cri des leurs qui est qui a trouvé
écho auprès de la société civile auprès
des organisations internationales auprès
des ong vous étiez auprès de la
population qui demande à ce que le
gouvernement puisse prendre des mesures
radicales on avait critiqué le président
karzaï qui avait convoqué une cellule de
crise au palais de carthage il ya une
semaine trop tard pour le personnel
soignant mais surtout pour paraître de
politiciens notamment de l'opposition
qui ont déclaré que ces mesures ont été
prises trop tardivement
la campagne de vaccination elle peine à
décoller la tunisie manqué beaucoup de
vaccins le gouvernement essaie de
développer ses partenariats avec les
pays est producteur de vaccins
malentendants beaucoup de dons sont
faits à la tunisie notamment les émirats
arabes unis qui ont fait un don de 500
mille doses à la tunisie cinq cent mille
doses de vaccin la tunisie attend encore
la livraison de vaccins spoutnik encore
johnson & johnson carthage a fait savoir
qu'il appelait à l'aide sa diaspora
notamment celles en france pour venir en
aide au système de santé ici en tunisie
deux pays voisins ont apporté leur aide
à la tunisie notamment l'egypte qui a
livré à deux avions militaires plainte
de deux de médicaments et de produits et
d'appareils et médicales ici à tunis
également le qatar qui a livré un
hôpital de campagne et puis des
respirateurs mais la situation reste
quand même critique beaucoup de pays ont
passé la tunisie rouge notamment le cas
de la libye son pays voisin et qui a
fait un point de liaison avec beth chebi
donc en direct nuit tunis les états unis
à présentes se prépare à prendre des
mesures face à l'émergence du variant
delta des représentants de pfizer
doivent rencontrer ce lundi les
autorités sanitaires américaines pour
plus de précisions retrouve tout de
suite notre reporter thomas bonnet en
direct de washington vos soir thomas on
parle de la possible mise en place d'une
troisième dose dans les mois à venir
c'est bien ça oui tout à fait cette
réunion se tient parce que justement
pfizer a demandé l'autorisation auprès
des autorités sanitaires américaines de
pouvoir mettre en place cette fameuse
troisième dose il s'appuie sur une étude
de pfizer qui affirme que cette
troisième dose permet d'augmenter de 5 à
10 fois le nombre d'anticorps auprès des
personnes ayant déjà reçu deux
injections les appelle cela un booster
shot un booster d'immunité qui
permettrait de lutter également plus
efficacement contre les variants et qui
serait selon pfizer nécessaires dans les
12 prochains mois pour les personnes
vaccinées alors il ya un certain nombre
de critiques quand même parce que
beaucoup estiment que ce n'est pas à une
entreprise privée et encore moins
un laboratoire pharmaceutique et
d'imposer en quelque sorte le calendrier
de cette campagne de vaccination aux
états unis du côté des autorités
américaines pour l'instant c'est une
piste qui n'est pas complètement écartée
mais elle ne s'est pas prononcé non plus
en faveur de cette troisième dose écouté
par exemple le docteur le docteur
anthony fauci
à l'heure actuelle étant donné les
résultats les informations que nous
avons nous n'avons pas besoin
d'administrer une troisième dose cela ne
veut pas dire qu'on s'arrête là il ya
des études qui sont menées en ce moment
au sujet de la faisabilité pour voir si
et quand nous devrions booster la
population alors la porte parole de la
maison blanche a également été interrogé
ce lundi sur cette possible troisième
dose elle se range derrière l'avis des
scientifiques et donc notamment du
docteur anthony fochi il faut aussi
noter que l'om est elle s'est plutôt
prononcé contre cette troisième dose en
expliquant qu'il fallait d'abord à
vacciner largement la population
mondiale avant justement de mettre en
place cette troisième dose alors du côté
du gouvernement américain la priorité de
toute façon pour l'instant c'est d'abord
de vacciner le plus possible la
population la population américaine
vacciner aujourd'hui à hauteur de 48%
48% des américains qui sont complètement
vaccinés dans le pays c'est insuffisant
pour les autorités sanitaires
américaines alors c'est pour cette
raison que joe biden a annoncé la
semaine dernière un certain nombre de
mesures avec notamment une campagne de
porte porte à porte qui va être lancée
notamment dans les états où la
vaccination est inférieur à ce qu'on
peut connaître par exemple dans les
grandes villes on sait que dans certains
états du sud des états unis
le nombre de personnes vaccinées est
inférieur à la moitié de la population
c'est donc pour cette raison qu'il va y
avoir une campagne de porte à porte qui
va être lancée très prochainement
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington est en avance sur la
vaccination israël franchi une nouvelle
étape le pays a commencé ce matin
administré une troisième dose de vaccin
anti qu'ovide aux personnes les plus
vulnérables
alors que ces dernières semaines
nombre de cas est reparti à la hausse
sur fond de propagation du variant delta
ce qui a conduit les autorités à
réintroduire certaines mesures comme le
port du masque dans les lieux publics
fermés
le ministre de la santé a publié une
liste des types de patients pouvant
bénéficier de cette troisième injection
j'ai subi une greffe cardiaque il ya
treize ans j'ai reçu deux doses de
vaccin et maintenant la troisième
j'espère que grâce à la médecine de
pointe à l'hôpital sheba le vaccin nous
protégera de la maladie et des variants
qui sont arrivés dans le pays
notre système immunitaire est faible et
le coronavirus peut nous atteindre
gravement
alors quand j'ai été appelé par une
clinique de transplantation cardiaque
pour recevoir la troisième dose de
vaccin je n'ai pas hésité un instant
je suis venu j'ai reçu le vaccin et je
me sens bien nous commençons à
administrer une troisième dose de vaccin
anti coronavirus aux patients ayant subi
une transplantation cardiaque dans notre
clinique
nous sommes très contents que cela
arrive car nous avons des preuves que le
coronavirus est associé à une morbidité
et une mortalité élevée chez nos
patients
il y a également des preuves que de 2,2
vaccin ne suffisent pas pour nos
patients comparé à la population
générale reste avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de la rencontre
amos contre sergueï lavrov et l'envoyé
spécial du président américain john
kerry
les deux hommes doivent discuter des
questions liées au climat et d'une
éventuelle coopération et puis direction
l'espagne avec la prise de fonction du
nouveau gouvernement de pedro sanchez
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il concrètement pour vous
depuis que le graet ci est officiel les
systèmes douaniers étaient compliquées
par la mise en oeuvre du rexy le vrai
sujet c'est celui de faire dialoguer les
douaniers français les poignées
britannique est ce qui m'inquiète dans
le bric side c'est pas le président
c'est la bureaucratie du brics comment
ça va se passer par exemple pour l'été
qui arrive la côte d'azur verra peu ou
pas d'anglais
je suspecte effectivement le
gouvernement britannique d'essayer de
convaincre les britanniques de rester en
grande bretagne pour faciliter la
relance de l'économie britannique par
rapport à la crise sanitaire
le pays n'a pas pris la bonne décision
et nous la respectons et donc une forme
de fatalité
m
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas un oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
ses accusations elle pose quand même la
question du traitement des dissidents
par votre mouvement si des accusations
politiques qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les allégations portées devant la
justice espagnole
nous n'avons jamais expulsé les les
organisations des droits de l'homme ni
la presse alors que le maroc les ont
occupés aujourd'hui sont servis est-ce
que désormais il ya un risque de voir
s'installer un conflit militaire sur la
durée les lignes rouges sont déjà
franchi qu'on a guère a commencé après
que le maroc a annexé encore et partie
de notre territoire nous avons accepté
un plan de paix qui consiste à
l'organisation d'un référendum
d'intervention vous laisser les
sahraouis le choix de choisir le futur
de choisir entre l'indépendance et
l'intégration maroc à savoir que ce
n'est pas une partie du territoire
marocain
au carrefour d'une pollution insultes et
d'une nécessité technologique absolue
les terreur sont au coeur des défis du
21e siècle c'est un enjeu stratégique
pour tous les prix puisque leur accès
est aujourd'hui principalement chinois
en l'état actuel des capacités minières
connu la part chinoise et réserve
mondiale est de l'ordre de 37 % dans la
cadre de la guerre commerciale avec les
états unis la chine utilise sa position
comme levier de négociations mais il est
clair qu'avec les pénuries et les
tensions que nous allons connaître sur
certaines terreur il faut envisager
d'autres solutions
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez john kerry et
l'envoyé spécial du président américain
pour le climat était à moscou ce lundi
il s'est entretenu avec le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov au menu notamment le changement
climatique à quatre mois de la
conférence des nations unies et
précision de notre correspondante
verhaeghe hoffman la russie et les etats
unis ont vraiment besoin de coopérer a
déclaré l'envoyé spécial des etats-unis
pour le climat john kerry en visite à
moscou pour plusieurs jours il a
rencontré aujourd'hui le chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
je vous propose d'écouter sur évidemment
il y à certaines divergences dans les
relations entre nos pays mais nous
étions ravis que le président poutine
aient pris part au sommet au sommet
virtuel qui a eu lieu en avril
nous recherchons des éléments rationnels
et prévisible dans nos relations
la clé c'est d'être capable de traiter
de la question des changements
climatiques à part c'est extrêmement
important c'est essentiel nous avons
vraiment besoin de coopérer parce que si
on ne fait pas cent entre 2020 et 2030
nous ne pourrons pas limiter la hausse
des températures à 1,5 degré est arrivé
à zéro émission
les enjeux ne peuvent pas être plus
élevé je crois quant au chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
il a déclaré que la russie attaché une
grande importance aux problèmes liés au
changement climatique dans le monde et
qu'elle continuerait à coopérer
activement sur ces questions et coûter
cher monsieur le représentant spécial du
président cher john chers collègues nous
estimons que votre visite à moscou et
très opportune la russie attache une
grande importance aux problèmes liés au
changement climatique dans le monde
et continuera à coopérer activement sur
les questions climatiques dans le cadre
des plateformes internationales en
premier lieu avec les signataires de la
convention cadre des nations unies sur
les changements climatiques et
conformément à l'accord de paris nous
contribuerons à la recherche de
solutions collectives aux problèmes qui
se posent dans ce domaine en partant de
nos conditions nationales et de nos
objectifs de développement
socioéconomique dans ce contexte dans le
cadre de ce travail nous comptons sur
une coopération étroite avec les états
unis notamment dans le cadre des
négociations entre les membres de la
convention-cadre afin d'assurer le
succès de leur réunion à glasgow cet
automne je considère également votre
visite comme un signal important et
positif du point de vue du développement
de nos relations bilatérales de
l'élimination des tensions au sein de
celle-ci et de la mise en place d'un
travail professionnel et de fonds dans
les domaines où nous pouvons trouver des
dénominateurs communs
ce n'est pas la première fois que john
kerry sergey lavrov se voient pour
discuter de la problématique du
réchauffement climatique la dernière
rencontre lavrov kerry a eu lieu à new
delhi en avril lors de la visite de
travail du chef de la diplomatie russe
sergueï lavrov
un inde ensuite le 1er juillet ils ont
eu un entretien téléphonique consacrée à
la coopération russo américaine en
matière du climat c'est lors de cet
échange que les diplomates se sont mis
d'accord de poursuivre des contacts
réguliers dans l'esprit du sommet
poutine baden qui a eu lieu le 16 juin à
genève
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
l'aude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir fou
merci d'être avec nous une rencontre
donc entre savez sergueï lavrov et john
kerry à moscou après donc le sommet à
genève du 16 mai entre réunir poutine et
joe biden est ce qu'on peut y voir un
réchauffement diplomatique entre les
deux pays
oui bien sûr on peut y voir un
réchauffement diplomatique entre les
deux pays et je crois que d'ailleurs
cette visite constitue la meilleure
démonstration de la méthode sur laquelle
les deux présidents le président
bayonnais le président poutine se sont
mis d'accord à genève à savoir
identifier des sujets jeux prévus si
possible des sujets concrets sur
lesquels il ya un intérêt commun des
deux parties et sur lesquels on doit
faire des progrès sur lesquels on peut
faire des progrès et ses progrès n'étant
pas du tout conditionné par les sujets
sur lesquels on reste en désaccord
autrement dit on peut discuter du
réchauffement climatique mais à genève
on a dit aussi qu'on pouvait discuter du
contrôle des armements
on a dit aussi qu'on veut discuter de
cybersécurité même si on n'est pas
d'accord sur les droits de l'homme ou
sur d'autres sujets qui touchent par
exemple à l'ukraine cette méthode est
donc maintenant en application et ce
n'est pas par hasard que on a choisi le
réchauffement climatique pour la mettre
en marche parce que il y a urgence comme
les deux ministres viennent de le dire
l'urgence c'est qu'il y à une coop 26 à
glasgow
au début du mois de novembre et que
cette coop 26 il faut la préparer et que
par conséquent il faut en discuter
surtout entre deux pays qui sont parmi
les très gros pollueurs émetteurs de co2
il ya là deux autres la chine et l'inde
et a eu quatre jeux sont les plus les
plus gros émetteurs de co2 par
combustion de carbone par conséquent il
est nécessaire de parler et de préparer
les négociations de glasgow
j'ajouterai que le messager
est particulièrement indiqué pour tester
cette méthode puisque comme l'a dit
votre journaliste john kerry connaît
très bien sergueï lavrov
lorsqu'il était secrétaire d'état
d'obama pendant le deuxième mandat du
président des états unis
eh bien ils se sont fréquemment
rencontrés ils se connaissent par
conséquent très bien et on voit bien qu
il que ce sont de 2,2 fin diplomate
c'est à dire que la méthode qu'ils
appliquent la est une méthode très
souvent utilisé dans la diplomatie dans
la diplomatie on identifie les sujets
sur lesquels on peut progresser sur
laquelle on peut se mettre d'accord
et puis on l'espère plus tard des sujets
plus difficiles où même les sujets qui
fâchent
il ya d'ailleurs eu vendredi dernier une
autre expérience dans la matière au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
tout le monde était très surpris que
russie etats-unis présentent une
résolution conjointe pour maintenir
probablement pour un an le couloir
humanitaire qui permet de maintenir en
vie un certain nombre de personnes dans
la poche d'idlib en syrie on croyait que
la russie s'y opposerait eh bien il ya
eu une résolution conjointe qui a fait
l'unanimité du conseil de sécurité
quels sont au club blanchemaison pour un
sac à il avancé john kerry les réels
enjeux de cet entretien sur le climat le
réel enjeu c'est comme l'on dit tout à
l'heure les deux personnalités qui se
rencontraient à moscou pratiquement tout
le monde est d'accord sur le fait qu'il
faut arriver à la neutralité carbone en
2050 alors 2050 ça paraît facile parce
que c'est loin mais à glasgow
chaque pays participant sera invité à
faire des annonces personnelles pas à
prendre des engagements des engagements
chiffrés et également un cheminement
pour arriver à ce résultat
lointain or actuellement les courbes de
la pollution les courbes d'émissions de
co2 ne sont pas très encourageantes
il ya tout lieu de penser qu
actuellement les objectifs que s'était
fixés
la conférence de paris la coop 21 ne
seront pas respectées il faut donc
renforcer les efforts et on sent bien
que dans les milieux politiques dans la
société civile des différents pays il y
à une pression dans ce sens les villes
les régions les grandes entreprises
prennent des décisions dans ce sens avec
ou sans le consentement des états dans
lesquels elles se trouvent
on a bien vu quand monsieur trump est
sortie de l'accord de paris est bien
certain nombre de régions un certain
nombre de villes
un certain nombre d'entreprises ont fait
savoir qu'elles continueraient
d'appliquer ses conclusions et ses
résolutions
donc c'est important que de pays comme
la russie et les etats-unis décident
devraient ensemble dans cette
négociation à glasgow le sommet de
genève 1 on en parlait tout à l'heure
entre vladimir poutine et joe biden
entre ces deux pays ont renforcé leur
coopération vous nous l'avez expliqué
claude mais toujours rien du côté de
leurs rapports avec la russie pourquoi
l'union européenne s'obstine t elle
s'obstine tél je vais y arriver elle pas
des log et avec la russie
question de méthode en effet le 24 juin
le conseil européen n'a pas pu aboutir à
un accord
la france et l'allemagne avaient proposé
de reprendre lé sommet semestriel qui
avait lieu jusqu'à la fin 2013
entre l'union européenne et la russie et
sept états membres s'y sont opposés
alors vous me direz il en reste 20
autres qui étaient d'accord ou qui
pouvaient accepter la réunion n'avait
pas été très bien préparé peut-être
madame merkel aurait dû prendre aurait
pu prendre la tâche un certain nombre
d'autres états membres qui sont
favorables à ce dialogue par exemple par
exemple elle think i qui aurait
peut-être pu amoindrir les réserves de
la suède par rapport à cet accord
peut-être aussi d'autres pays auraient
pu parler à la pologne et parler aux
pays baltes pour qu'ils ne mettent pas
un
un veto absolu à la reprise de ces
réunions qui ont encore une fois été
très régulière jusqu'en 2014
alors maintenant il faut prendre la
méthode diplomatique classique
c'est-à-dire identifier des projets des
sujets sur lesquels on peut faire des
progrès qui sont des parce que ce sont
des sujets d'intérêt commun et se réunir
pour en discuter
alors peut-être faut-il différencier les
interlocuteurs peut-être faut-il
différencier aussi le format des
réunions il se trouve que la france a
exercé la présidence du conseil de
l'union européenne au semestre prochain
et rien n'empêche la france en effet
dans cette perspective de prendre des
initiatives et s'il ya un blocage de tel
ou tel pays est bien de faire des
réunions informelles avec les pays qui
le souhaitent pour discuter avec la
russie sur les sujets d'intérêts communs
sur lesquels nous devons aboutir à des
résultats d'ici là de toute manière ils
eurent à glasgow
à la veille de glasgow il y aura le g20
auquel participent l'union européenne et
un certain nombre des plus grands états
membres de l'union européenne
par conséquent ces sujets seront évoqués
au g20 à la veille de glasgow
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
et en espagne à présent le premier
ministre remanie son cabinet le
gouvernement espagnol et rajeunie et
féminisée
l'objectif redonner un nouveau souffle
au mandat du socialiste pedro sanchez
les explications avec à clémentine lors
des deux récentes chaise refait et
rajeuni son équipe le premier ministre
espagnol a annoncé qu'il allait remanier
son gouvernement
au total ce sont sept ministres qui
quittent le bateau tout d'abord il ya
carmen calvo la première vice présidente
espagnole qui s'en va elle avait
notamment dû faire face à plusieurs
déconvenues politique face aux membres
du gouvernement de la gauche radicale
podemos le ministre de la justice s'en
va aussi juan carlos campos quitte le
gouvernement
et on se souviendra de lui comme le
ministre qui avait accordé les grâces
aux prisonniers politiques catalans
une décision qui n'a pas fait
l'unanimité ici en espagne
enfin du côté du ministère des affaires
étrangères il ya aussi du changement
mais cette fois les français peuvent
savoir de qui il s'agit puisque manuel
alvarez bono est actuellement
l'ambassadeur d'espagne en france et
c'est lui qui avait annoncé il ya
quelques jours que les touristes
français ne craignez rien en espagne
alors que la situation sanitaire
pourrait plutôt dire le contraire alors
ce remaniement c'est une surprise ici en
espagne
il était bien sûr prévu mais il est
beaucoup plus conséquent que ce à quoi
on s'attendait
ça notre côté le gouvernement est
largement rajeuni la moyenne d'âge tombe
à 50 ans et puis c'est un gouvernement
aussi très féminin en compte 14
ministres femmes pour neuf ministres
hommes
en somme c'est donc une équipe flambant
neuf pour nous donner un nouveau souffle
à pedro sanchez après la déconvenue
politique en mai dernier à madrid où la
gauche a perdu les élections régionales
et pour en parler nous sommes avec à
nicolas klain spécialiste de l'espagne
contemporaine hauteur de comprendre
l'espagne d'aujourd'hui manuel de
civilisation aux éditions ellipses
soir nicolas klain merci d'être avec
nous pedro sanchez qui a donc présenté
un ce remaniement pour préparer la
relance économique officiellement c'est
le principal défi du gouvernement
aujourd'hui
alors c'est un des défis du gouvernement
bien évidemment puisque les différentes
mesures qui ont été prises au cours de
l'année 2020 et même au début de l'année
2002 21 dans le cadre de la pandémie
coronavirus comme confinement général de
mars à début juin
fin mai début juin 2020 ont eu des
conséquences très nette et très néfastes
sur l'économie espagnole donc c'est un
des défis
un autre défi ça va être de poursuivre
la campagne de vaccination toujours
contre la copie 19 campagne de
vaccination qui est très avancé 1
espagne plus qu'en france c'est pour ça
que quand la france donne des leçons sur
la situation sanitaire à l'espagne on
peut sourire disons et puis il va y
avoir également d'autres problématiques
auxquelles devra s'atteler ce nouveau
gouvernement ce gouvernement remanié
la problématique territoriale avec la
catalogne mais pas seulement
problématique beaucoup plus large
les thématiques de société par exemple
la place des femmes également plusieurs
polémiques récentes et des faits divers
tragiques autour de l'homophobie en
espagne enfin voilà différentes
différents défis qui ne sont pas des
moindres pour ce nouveau gouvernement ce
remaniement du gouvernement c'était
inévitable également pour préparer les
prochaines élections législatives et
régionales de 2023
alors cela semblait effectivement
inévitable la rumeur courait depuis déjà
plusieurs semaines pour plusieurs mois
c'est le choix de la date qui est un
petit peu surprenant parce qu'on est
quand même au début des vacances d'été
peut-être que ce
remaniement ou raid était plus attendue
à la rentrée en septembre
il est vrai que le gouvernement de pedro
sanchez le parti socialiste et ses
alliés dont il dispose et moss sont en
mauvaise posture dans les nombreux
sondages d'opinion y compris au niveau
national qui sont sortis depuis les
élections régionales mme adrienne du 4
mai dernier comme le rappelait votre
sujet ça a été une déconvenue pour la
gauche très largement et en particulier
pour les socialistes
et il est vrai que pedrosa en chef
espère avec ce gouvernement donner un
nouveau souffle à la législature qui a
fait suite aux élections de novembre
2019 et donc en vue des élections
régionales et municipales du premier
semestre 2023 probablement aux alentours
d'avril mai et des élections générales
qui pour le moment sont prévues au
dernier trimestre de l'année 2000 23
probablement novembre ou décembre
63 % de femmes plus jeunes ce
gouvernement également le nouveau la
nouvelle équipe de pedro sanchez se veut
aussi un moyen de séduire la jeunesse
alors c'est évidemment ce qui est
affiché parce qu'en réalité la jeunesse
espagnole on le voit à travers non
seulement les enquêtes d'opinion mais
aussi les élections qui ont lieu depuis
à peu près un an un an et demi
la jeunesse se détournent du
gouvernement de coalition non seulement
des socialistes mais aussi de la gauche
radicale entre guillemets dont lisa se
poser most qui pourtant avait fait de la
jeunesse
un de ses principaux thèmes de campagne
un de ses principaux thèmes politiques
et la jeunesse représentés pour cette
frange de la politique espagnole de
l'arc parlementaire une force
or on voit que la jeunesse se détournent
de ces forces là notamment au profit de
la droite en partie le parti populaire
la droite on va dire classique mais
aussi la droite radicale ou extrême
droite de vox qui séduit assez
et intensément la jeunesse en tout cas
plus que ce qu'on pouvait imaginer
donc évidemment la jeunesse c'est un
comment on peut l'expliquer tout d'abord
parce que les attentes et les défis
auxquels doit faire face la jeunesse en
espagne le chômage les problèmes
d'émancipation l'accès au logement le
problème de la maternité et de la
paternité
tous ces problèmes là pour le moment
n'ont pas été résolus par la gauche et
il semblerait que la gauche apparaissent
aujourd'hui relativement peu crédible
qu'on verra si ça change mais en tout
cas relativement peu crédible pour les
résoudre et par ailleurs la jeunesse
espagnole a été séduite en tout cas pour
une partie d'entre elles bien sûr par un
certain nombre de thématiques et d'
approche de la droite de la droite
radicale espagnol sur des questions de
liberté économique individuel
donc je crois que là est véritablement
on voit des changements sociologiques se
produire on verra s'il se poursuivre ou
pas il ya eu également un parmi les
événements de ces dernières semaines la
grâce des leaders catalans est-ce
qu'elle a fragilisé le parti de ce pedro
sanchez c'est une décision qui a été
jugées impopulaires par les espagnols
alors là aussi toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion dont on dispose montrent
qu'une majorité des espagnols l'une des
sondés favorables à cette grâce je me
permets juste ici d'apporter un
correctif amical à votre journaliste qui
a parlé de prisonniers politiques
catalans savent ce qu'est ce que
proclament les anciens prisonniers
ancien responsable séparatistes catalan
il reconnu comme tel par personne ce
sont des hommes politiques en prison ce
qui n'est pas la même chose
donc effectivement cette décision de
grâce a été très mal prise par une
majorité d'espagnols y compris parmi les
électeurs du parti socialiste faut
comprendre qu'en plus cette décision de
grâce n'avait absolument pas été
annoncée par pedro sanchez lors des
différentes campagnes législatives des
deux campagnes législatives de 2010 9 et
qu'au contraire ils avaient
réaffirmé à plusieurs reprises que qu'il
souhaitait que ses dirigeants
emprisonnés fassent leur peine de prison
jusqu'au bout en réalité c'est
simplement un geste qu'il attendait de
faire pour se concilier des partis
séparatistes au parlement national
espagnol afin de pouvoir terminer la
présente législature puisque le
gouvernement c'est un chat est en
minorité au parlement il faut le
rappeler
merci nicolas klain je rappelle
d'engager spécialistes un d'espagne
contemporaine hauteur de comprendre
l'espagne d'aujourd'hui manuel de
civilisation aux éditions ellipses
sommes dans le reste de l'actualité à
cuba joe biden appelle le gouvernement
cubain entendre son peuple et son appel
vibrant à la liberté réponse au
président miguel diaz cannelle qui
accuse les etats-unis de vouloir
provoquer des troubles sociaux des
milliers de cubains sont descendus hier
dans la rue pour protester notamment
contre la crise économique qu'ils
subissent de plein fouet on fait le
point avec françois ses skis leach scène
rare dans les rues de la havane
policiers et manifestants s'affrontent
dans la capitale cubaine
ce dimanche des milliers de personnes
ont manifesté à travers le pays en
colère
à bas la dictature
à bas les castro des manifestations
inédites contre le gouvernement en
réaction le président cubain miguel diaz
cannes elle appelle ses partisans à
descendre dans la rue
c'est pourquoi nous appelons également
tous les révolutionnaires du pays tous
les communistes à sortir dans la rue
dans tous les endroits où ces
provocations avoir lieu aujourd'hui à
partir de maintenant et pendant tout
séjour et à les affronter avec
détermination avec fermeté et avec
courage conséquences de cette escalade
des tensions entre manifestants et
contre-manifestants dans certains
quartiers de la havane une contestation
sur fond de crise économique la pire
depuis trente ans selon certains
observateurs crise que la pandémie de
kovy 19 ne fait qu'aggraver
depuis qu'elle sévisse les pénuries
d'aliments de médicaments sont
permanentes et l'électricité est coupée
plusieurs heures par jour dans le même
temps cuba enregistrent de nouveau
record de contamination et de morts dus
aux coronavirus en visite dans les rues
de san antonio de los banios le
président cubain accuse au milieu de
cette situation et comme si des foyers
de pandémie n'avait pas existé dans le
monde entier
la mafia cubano américaine qui paye très
bien les réseaux sociaux les youtuber
les influenceurs contre cuba a créé
toute une compagne en prenant comme
prétexte la situation dans la province
de montagnards comme celle de la
situation à cuba
ils ont appelé à des manifestations dans
tous les régions du pays
à miami la plus cubaine des villes
américaines
des milliers de personnes ont apporté
leur soutien aux manifestations
antigouvernementales ces jeunes
d'aujourd'hui ont finalement dit assez
c'est assez nous allons faire ce que nos
parents n'ont pas pu faire et c'est
pourquoi maintenant les jeunes à cuba au
finalement ouvert les yeux et nous
sommes ici avec eux cubains nous sommes
ici avec vous depuis les etats-unis sous
embargo américain depuis 1962
le gouvernement cubain s'est dit prêt à
défendre la révolution coûte que coûte
une situation suivie de très près par
washington mettant en garde la havane
contre tout usage de la violence à
l'encontre de manifestants pacifiques
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fin de cette émission prochain
point complet sur l'actualité dans
quelques minutes
[Musique]
vous dirigez une des plus vieilles et
sans doute d'une des plus importantes
compagnies de taxis en france l'activité
a repris sdap elmander paris ou pas les
chauffeurs de taxi affiliés à notre
plateforme ont à peu près le même nombre
de courses par jour il avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de touristes
étrangers
les chauffeurs sont un peu à la peine
garé yaqub ya 5 6 ans vous aviez un
monopole est sûre ce est arrivée la
concurrente bb&t gros gros choc d'offre
on est passé de on a doublé les 20000 à
45 mille véhicules
oui on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur les
mobilités réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque usage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk sommes au bord
de la volga le plus long fleuve d'europe
nous sommes à chevaux ksari
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à berlin on est
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois celle en profiter
en 2011
elle ne demande pas un petit peu non ah
oui et c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les les
[Musique]